I like the strawberry mushroom combo
they put up there I was like I respect
that that Beatles vibe
are we live though do we believe it
I don't know if I'd trust it
that's not a fun message yeah let's see
here
that happened nope that's a lot a lot of
symbols for it and error
there we go we are guys uh it wouldn't
be a live stream without us wondering if
we're live but it's okay the computer is
doing fine it's figured it all out and
uh we are excited to be here with you
guys let us know if you can hear us I
see a lot of yeses in the comments I see
Audrey Saint Seer I see Cooper I see doe
eyes Christian unpronounceable it's not
a challenge my friend GTA 5 GTA say star
wow that's a hell of a name you got
there Von Rouge Jordan Garza loves Joe
Coy that's us ooh we got a ship name we
are joking I like that and then and then
Joe Coy can come in and collab with us
and confuse everyone that's only fair uh
yeah the Best comedian of all time
oh well you know his taste is immaculate
absolutely uh guys just want to say
thank you first and foremost for being
here for joining us on a Saturday
morning you could be watching cartoons
right now but instead you are here to
talk about the MCU the DCU movies in
general and uh hey just want to share
the appreciation with you I just see we
just got a Super Chat thank you so much
uh yeah if you're new to the stream the
way these things work is we're gonna try
and hop around between all the different
versions of the chat help to make all of
you hopefully feel appreciated and like
your time is being valued however if you
want to guarantee that we read off your
question and address it uh super chats
or streamlabs are the best way to do
that we will do not every single one
right we will not end the stream this is
the one time we're looking at yourself
can't help just because I went up and
down and I went both and like Greg
wasn't here to yell at me right I was
like I'm gonna navigate narcissism and
productivity yeah like a good Saturday
morning bowling yeah if you want to
guarantee your question to be read and
our undying gratitude that is the way to
do it but we appreciate the all of you
and uh and yeah the the live chat is
especially the life's blood of these
streams and thank you so much Jeff
Carroll we will get to you very shortly
of your favorite uh working stand-up
comedian oh working good question
probably Mariner probably Mark Maron
really yeah I I love uh The Vibes I love
the growth that man has gone through
um but hey you know what else I love koi
is a little bit of casting news I feel
like we should kick things off today
with a little bit of casting news and
yes if you are interested again in
throwing us a question I know probably a
lot of the news uh that Greg has
compiled for us to talk about today will
probably be stuff that's on your guys
mind so we're gonna hop pretty quick
into the Super chats but we're gonna
start here we're just uh yeah the sort
of uh top rumors casting of the week uh
streamlabs link is pinned currently at
the top of the chat and uh yeah let's
hop into this because we got both DC and
Marvel rumors and uh I guess first and
foremost it would be good to start off
with the Superman casting uh potential
casting with a few different people
rumored the first one being a name that
I am was hither too unfamiliar with the
guy named David korenzwet
um red hairline yeah great hairline
great jawline and I'm gonna try and pull
them up here real quick on the screen so
that you guys can see in fact maybe we
will uh just shift on over into our
slightly adjusted uh format here but
this guy's got you know an interesting
uh look for Superman certainly let me
try and drag this over here we're doing
great now he's Batman oh now he's
Superman there you go yes yeah that's
all you need to know
and then yeah if we could just get some
little spectacles uh for Clark Kent but
yeah that is uh David korenzwet also
known from a current has been cast in
the new twister sequel so you know Star
Is On The Rise
um I always talk about that with casting
like where they are in their career is
really important and that twister movies
cast is bananas so actually ironically
him getting cast in twister makes me
believe this rumor more sure no
absolutely yes because you know
oftentimes I think that'll happen behind
the scenes is when you know some kind of
big piece of casting swirls around you
know then you get that word of mouth
like this guy's great gotta get on that
train you know and I also think that
like someone just said can the guy act I
actually don't know his work but with
the cast of Twister yeah I have to be
able to because it's like that cast is
stacked like you cannot keep up with
people unless you can like you know keep
up with people I mean I guess I've never
Associated twister with being like a
thespian Terry always Phillip Seymour
Hoffman Bill Pullman I mean great cast
uh I'm not denying Cinema it's a great
cast of just saying Helen Hunt it's
there's cheese to that movie though but
he's best known at the moment for a
pearl is the movie that most gets
brought up uh with his you know uh film
mug thus far he was also on the
Hollywood miniseries House of Cards uh
some other things and that and that
seems like a decent place to start
actually I don't know I mean there are
again a couple other guys listed here
and I'll bring those images back up but
uh of the of the few I've seen I thought
you know especially that Superman suit
mock-up they did of him was actually
pretty good but I put it to the chat and
before we we get Coy's opinion what do
you guys think of uh David
as I'm trying to commit that there's
some people's names you just cannot
commit to them this is the first round
of casting when I've felt old because I
do not know a lot of these names and I'm
like oh all right the youngins but it's
youths and I think that's good though I
don't know it's great yeah I think uh
the less we know a little bit sort of
the the better in a way
um because again I think you want
somebody a little bit new for a role
like this that is so iconic and that is
yeah being sort of redefined again you
know you're gonna need somebody who
isn't going to bring a whole bunch of
other baggage kind of like it growing on
me seems great less known says Jen he's
gonna need those CGI muscles says Adrian
oh you got time you got time to get
gains you got yes you got game time
don't even worry about it y'all okay so
here we go so here's the picture of him
uh either somebody mocked up as actual
Superman and in that mode like he
actually to me
I mean the other images that I'm about
to pull up you know they have like
beards and stuff so like it's a little
trickier white out the draw line for me
but that's not as important as acting so
like I just like it's it's it's almost
but you know I'm just acknowledging a
nice square jaw we also have in the
running a guy named Tom Brittany it's a
new name to me I've not heard this at
all yet what is this which uh command
machine
sorry about this guys there you go
there's there's old Tom Bridge Ryan
James I totally said Pullman instead of
Paxton Bill Paxton I apologize wow I did
I did what do you think this is Twisters
I mean uh some other faction movie damn
it we're doing great we're doing great
on Saturday morning so there we go so
here's um another of our contenders here
Tom Brittany which um you know I I he
reminds me we're going to talk about
fantastic forecasting in a minute and he
looks like you can play the thing
to me all day
um but you know yeah British actor so
certainly we know that uh he would do a
good job and and then this guy Andrew
Richardson uh who I know I've seen
before uh obviously very scruffed out
he's got kind of a narrow face for Soups
it's looking yeah yeah which I mean
Superman All-American boy gotta be able
to hug him somebody said that's Jimmy
Olsen that is definitely more Jimmy
Olsen I could definitely see that good
on you uh Mikey cheers cheers to you
um but yeah
what do you guys think of these three
potential casting choices and do you
have a particular name that you would
throw in as a fan cast it's funny too
because like listening to all this stuff
and James Gunn has been very vocal about
when people are like not even at all in
the running so these recent bouts of you
know potential casting have me kind of
suspicious I actually just put out a
thing like an hour ago saying that uh
he's gonna slow down on attacking every
rumor because he thinks people are
getting more attention like he's like
people are doing it for my attention and
also one of the rumors is half true and
also he's storyboarding Superman so he's
busy and also people are getting to the
point where it's a negatively obnoxious
as much as he enjoys the hobby as much
as I enjoy the hobby there are times you
have to get to work
um so I personally don't know if any of
these are true I personally
um don't know any of their work which I
actually like I don't necessarily see
all three of them but I'm not the
YouTuber that goes like they don't look
like Superman so it's not it like I just
I don't I don't know uh I think judging
by people's looks alone isn't logical
and since I don't know they're acting I
really don't feel like I've got any
horse in the race here
that makes sense like I just because
yeah picking off looks is not a logical
way to cast yeah yeah no I I feel that
as well and yeah there's only so much
you can do I mean especially too because
again I think a lot of these rumored
names are people you're gonna have to
then go out and be like oh let me check
out this guy's work yeah and I'll be
happy to yeah when they announce it I
hope at Comic-Con depending on how
things go with the you know the strikes
and legalities and all the chaos I do
think announcing it at Comic-Con is
going to cause a surge in all of their
work I feel like in August I'm going to
be watching a lot of movies of whoever
is cast because I like that it's a more
unknown I think that's smart absolutely
and then the other side of the uh the
aisle before we hop into our super chats
as well as some of our other featured
stories is a fantastic forecasting uh
potentially uh there's Lex Luthor too
actually there's the Nicholas Holt Rumor
for Lex Luthor I'm the one guy that
likes Nick holtmore and Superman he's
been almost Superman twice he's almost
got cast as Superman two different times
and I honestly think those baby blues I
think his sweetness I think he's got an
alien quality to him in a very positive
way I think he's very huggable but
intense which is a thing Superman is I I
like Nicole for for Superman he's also
Wicked tall people don't realize how
tall Nicholas Holt is the dark Phoenix
Premiere had no idea humble he's like
six three uh and I don't know I like his
uh his his sweet naive innocence is a
war boy in Mad Max and ever since then
I've been like you'd be a good Superman
buddy that's put on like you know 40
pounds which he could you certainly
could yeah yeah
um I'm up seven and three months without
a trainer he could put on 40. like it's
people with like people with weights is
so interesting to people like he's too
skinny I'm like yeah but like the gym
exists
does it though does it though does it
though and then on the other side we
have a potential casting for both Sue
storm as well as uh uh Ben Grim Ben
Grimm our boy thing and uh the newest
rumor is that Emma Stone has reportedly
been offered Sue storm and that David
Diggs who I know you and I have both
been eagerly awaiting an MCU debut from
I mean not that everybody needs to be in
the MCU or whatever but he is one where
I would be so thrilled in and actually
for uh you know you're the expert I'll
let you take it away in a hot second but
especially for thing that was a choice I
heard and I went oh because I wouldn't
have thought it but at the same time I
could see it working and I could see him
working as both an interesting take on
Ben Grimm but also as you know the big
you know empathetic Rock Beast you know
yeah I personally think Emma Stone is
one of those choices where I was like
man I never even thought of that but
it's so perfect I love when there's a
casting choice that
huge actress uh exactly right for the
role my brain just didn't put it
together like she to me has the
hyperintellectualism the Cadence in Her
speech that like ability to keep up and
tolerate like an arrogant read like
there's something about the role she's
played where the arrogance of Ryan
Gosling in a Charming way like Ryan
Gosling has a confidence that borders on
arrogance depending on the role and Emma
Stone plays opposite Ryan Gosling for a
reason well I think Emma Stone's got a
steadfast Foundation of confidence that
can keep up with someone playing either
confident or arrogant she also is
familiar with the style of acting of
these big block posters and to me is
someone I'd love to see in a role for 10
years like she's a casting that I will
follow that actress like there's some
actors I'm like I'll see their work but
others actors I'm like I am excited for
the next 10 years of blah blah Emma
Stone is one of those and I feel like
Divi Diggs is an actor that I would like
his thing but I'd actually rather see
him in something where I'd see David
digs more like I liked if he digs on us
that I would prefer him not to be a
voice because I also so I feel like Divi
Diggs is so busy maybe it'd be better if
he can just jump in the booth and do
voice over work and then go back to
making like rap and writing and
producing blind spotting and acting like
you might want to play the thing because
it allows him his flexibility but I feel
like nah he's gonna be in the mocap suit
like I'd almost want to be digs his
[__] read
I mean I would be down for that too that
would be really cool I I so I was about
to say I mean do the Ryan Gosling dude
with all the Barbie press and he was
talking about like I'd love to be
immortal they haven't called I was like
there's their read and Sue
um but I I definitely I like these both
uh I definitely hear a little bit more
of a comedic tone to uh Ben Graham which
which he would suit like I think there
needs to be a broken comedy like he's
he's a broken man that like the comedy
comes from that and I think David could
play that if you've never seen blind
spot in the movie or the show he's got
like that in him
um I I've been really seeing a
Jason Siegel Seth Rogen on one side on
the other side I've always seen it as
Joel Edgerton or
um like a big lumbering so David works
for all of that sure so yes co-signed
all right all right I guess Emma Stone
idea like yeah and and Chad is going off
I think that the most heavily for Emma
Stone Those see the most uh uh
enthusiasm 80s kid from the 90s is down
uh Big D is okay with it uh Cho latte
wants an Asian Sue storm that would be
cool definitely Jen Jacinda loves David
digs a thousand percent
uh so you know okay and I'm actually I'm
happy to uh Ed Harris's legs Luther he's
way too old now like it would be cool it
would work but at the same time get off
my lawn Superman it would be a different
kind of movie
um but yeah and then leave any of your
fan castings I know in the super chats
we have uh some fan castings as well and
uh Muscle Man koi is definitely not
sleeping
hey we'll do a whole separate video just
recommending those and uh Dom says Adria
arahona uh ariar hono is a Top Choice
for Sue storm she's my Wonder Woman
She's My Wonder Woman too like right
there I'm glad we're no one can see that
fist bump nope
and uh definitely yeah Will Smith is
going to be Doctor Doom I think there's
just no way around that uh what's up
brick man Arts we're just about to hop
into some super chats but we're glad to
have you along for our little journey
here let's uh let's adjust the camera oh
looky there fandom Comics brings up a
good point David is doing more voiceover
work and he was just in Little Mermaid
so he's in the Disney wheelhouse right
now so I do think this this is a
plausible rumor and I do like it I just
want to see a lot of them he's just in
the house of mouse full-time now Ivan
he's vibing I gotta start watching uh
train spot I Gotta See Trainspotting the
movies blind spotting that's a reference
all right blind spotting uh is I think
one of the most important movies in the
last decade and it's probably the movie
I show people most Next In Bruges okay
it's hard to give higher praise not bad
I Love In Bruges as well and uh blind
spotting adds like the year that came
out everybody I know who saw it was like
this is my favorite movie of the year
that no one's talking about that that
isn't getting enough rewards
consideration and all that stuff and so
now I've been very anxious if it wasn't
for spider verse and the spider-verse
movie being like my whole ass life then
it would have been my movie of the year
but that's the year spiderverse came out
I guess I just got acknowledge
absolutely
it's James Gunn's favorite superhero
movie as per to that video he put out
this is genius I enjoyed his takes and
the timing and uh people he sees in good
hands absolutely and uh Jeremy Ram Coy
and John are definitely siblings and we
both grew up in Boston we can get
obviously oh now we can't Jeff Carroll
has our first Super Chat of the day uh
here where's where's the uh
there you go a little quiet that's for
you Jeff Carroll yes all right so Jeff
Carroll has more fan casts let's do this
oh I remember this guy so for Marvel we
got Cyclops Reggie Jean page I like his
arrogance I don't want to go each one of
you under the whole thing we should like
speed around each one sure let's go
through and then you can maybe like one
sentence uh resident page I think is
arrogance and has the look and has the
confidence and I think you need a
likable Cyclops while you don't want to
liken into it okay okay and he's the
he's the guy in now Dungeons and Dragons
yeah okay and then dazzler Hunter
Schaefer do not know that name my
dazzler is and will always be Taylor
Swift
okay all right I'm just gonna pull up
Hunter Schaefer on the side here so that
we have a visual reference uh but yes
okay
she's a model she is a model look at
that look at Hunter Schaefer right there
okay dazzler as a character that's a new
character to me what she turns sound
into energy and she's a pop star sick
she's awesome that's why Taylor Swift
sounds like Jiro from my hero Academia
he loved Adler she's awesome but also
Taylor Swift sounds like a good call
Gambit Jamie Campbell Bower
I've always seen Gambit as like very
very very from the streets and
Jamie Campbell Bauer has just a little
bit of britishness to him that I don't
know I think he could do it but I see
him as So Posh even when he was vechna I
was like that rich boy is angry uh but I
if I want to see it I want to see it I
can't see it so I want to see it okay
okay then next up we got gwenpool Kaylee
Cuoco I love gwenpool the character is
one of the best new characters in Marvel
she is genius and I have started to
forgive Kelly Cuoco for being a part of
the thing that hurt pop culture the most
in nerd culture since those ads about
Jack people beating up nerds uh Big Bang
Theory is the equivalent of the atlas
ads for pop culture so I don't love that
but she's great to Harley Quinn okay all
right all right and then uh who we got
next we got Mephisto Robert Carlisle
genius love it no notes good call I love
that actually that's terrific and the
thing Alan richson or Tom Hopper uh we
just finished both of those are great
and if you wanna if you want to join us
uh me and Greg for the reactions we got
him on the channel as well as over on
patreon uh sync up with our Reacher
reactions terrific Series on Amazon and
uh Poor Tom Cruise is
he's from uh Umbrella Academy yeah okay
so and then Tom Hopper he's uh yeah he's
the big guy yeah both very frail small
men both very petite gentlemen both tiny
little dudes can I say going to uh the
chaos of the fast X red carpet in Rome
it was insane that I was in front of the
Coliseum I was right next to Vin Diesel
and Jason Statham and all these like men
into this insane space and then Alan
Richton came over and I was just like
that's the craziest thing ever like he's
so large that like every the Coliseum
looked small next to Alan Richardson
that man is a giant specimen of just
Mass he's a real Gladiator dude I'm so
impressed by his like like The Rock in
here I think the only two people are I'm
like I gotta do push-ups right now like
right now it was impressive you got to
get them to train you a true dude if I
that's actually like a that's my
Make-a-Wish if I get cancer I'm gonna
have Alan Richton train me
before I want to go out jacked I got to
he does have an insane body big casket
DC Donna Troy Amber mid Thunder from
prey which uh hey I'll take Amber mid
thunder in anything these days
oh that's right yeah I've heard you say
that I think that's a good idea as well
x23 okay uh Sterling K Brown Martian
Manhunter love that he's personally my
Mr terrific but if he's gonna be in DC
anywhere I'm loving either one of these
because that'd be a leading role I won't
start looking around and leading role I
loved him in Black Panther but it wasn't
enough
and then who we got next Rose Wilson
Samara weaving I like that I want some
more weaving somewhere uh in comic book
she has a very like Illustrated face her
face is very
fascinating looking which I think suits
Comic characters into that
absolutely don't don't mind me
also is that okay that thing's flying
around Amber uh Sue storm someone said I
mean Amber Heard is uh definitely such a
loved figure I think it'll help sell
tickets absolutely
Greg just entered the room how does a
pause has taken does it look okay
we have a Greg can you base it off of
this oh that's fair
I know he's just there I'm gonna talk
about God God has entered them uh let's
see someone said uh Joe Rogan and Seth
Rogen as Jimmy and Bimi and Double
Dragon reboot that I mean that writes
itself
uh Megan thought he as Sue storm I
unfortunately do not know that name I'm
sorry I wish I could help Taryn ederson
for Captain Britain is fun Taryn
Edgerton is like the most fan casted
person ever uh but I always like these
ideas
um smarter we think would be a great
live-action spider Gwen I have thought
of that before actually I think she'd be
a great it'd be fun if she was
spider-gwen and gwenpool and like a
council of Gwen's I'd love to see a
multiversal Gwen situation
um hearts for Greg hearts for Greg all
the hearts for Greg uh what are we just
Austin's Butler Gambit's fun that one I
like a lot I feel like Austin Butler is
the American version of Jamie Campbell
Bower sure and I like it and I could I
can very much imagine and hear him doing
uh
the Gambit voice he'd fall into it for
five years and never Escape it yes I
could hear his Sherry with a little
Elvis in it yeah sorry he's just got
that thing that that could be so Cajun
yeah I like that a lot
I'm drinking a g fuel uh Kamehameha
strawberry lyshi to the to the people
asking in the chat I got a couple
questions on that gyllenha is Batman you
know I loved some Jakey Jake so yeah I'm
in for Gyllenhaal Batman always
all right where are we at static shock
Danny love I do not know Danny love but
uh I love static shock so if do you
think we will get a static shock thing
like in any anytime soon I think it's
gonna be in the later half of the first
chapter I think it's one of the 12
projects that isn't announced yet I
think static shock's coming okay because
I yeah like I that's one that for some
reason I think it's just yeah from like
you know growing up with the cartoons I
have been like
eagerly anticipating I want Caleb
McLaughlin playing so bad okay from
stranger things I think straight like
the that kid is so talented that scene
at the end of this for this new new
season I was like that is static like I
want that a lot oh sure talk about like
that passion the pathos he has the look
where he's like I could see him like in
the clothes that would you have to look
a certain way to make that look work you
know what I mean like he can wear
because when I met uh Caleb at the Creed
Premiere he was wearing like a ja
rule-esque
um Flack jacket he was wearing like a
bulletproof vest and like like uh big
jeans and I was like oh the 90s is back
and he's pulling it off but then on
stranger things he looks like a child in
a hoodie and like he can make both work
and I think static shock's outfit is so
Preposterous there's a look you need
okay so there's a little a little shot
of Danny love's face right there
uh you know I could see him he's done uh
he he doesn't have the the biggest
filmog just yet and he's done a lot of
like reality-based stuff from what I can
tell but it would be an interesting call
I would be curious to see what that
looks like but uh but uh dude from
stranger things I think is also a solid
call and then Jeff Carroll once again
dude thank you for your for your
triplicate generosity over here uh this
this is number three of five uh
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 at one point
he comes to Rockets cage I assume you
mean the high Evolution oh of course he
though the high Evo comes to Rockets
cage in distress his assistant saying he
needs to get back to treatment did I
miss why could his research have also
been about personal immortality I think
that was implied right yeah I I feel
like it's not ultimately important to
what it was and I'm sure that they can
make it important later but it does seem
like yeah it's just something to do with
his you know Evolution into you know
this being that certainly is part
machine now part you know whatever God
man being he was originally and then
yeah the additional powers and things
like that and I have to imagine that
yeah it would be something it to me it
read as something like a treatment yeah
to secure his immortality or to make it
so that you know he won't have to
confront you know yeah mortality in any
way you know so that he can be perfect
and I'm sure whatever that looks like is
certainly quite distressing everything
else he did was self-serving so I'm sure
that was too yeah absolutely fandom
Comics Mason Gooding is actually one of
my human torches
okay dang I got so many new names ready
with it man ready with it absolutely you
are that's what I like about you Coy
you're always game around I got answers
except for Danny love who looks friendly
yes
I think Greg has the TV I've seen that
it's very something's happening there's
a mouse going all over our screen and
it's like super intense uh but it's all
good it's all good it wouldn't be a real
rejects live stream without it uh do you
believe Juan Mora I believe in you and
uh we love you let's get your let's get
your uh little uh there you go everyone
can see your Super Chat do you believe
the MCU will have a different approach
with Victoria Alonso gone considering
she's been to blame for VFX in recent
years I think it's a hell of an
assumption to say she's been to blame
yeah I like I know she's in charge or
was in charge of you know communicating
with and and you know timelining that
stuff but I feel like so much of the
Mandate of the timeline for those
effects comes from you know the people
who decide the release dates and the
timelines for those things as well as
the budgets and whatnot so it's weird I
can I get why immediately you would
think that like oh they're having all
these VFX problems and the houses are
overworked and it's you know the effects
aren't looking as good as they could
certainly you would want to kind of give
that blame to her but at the same time I
don't know if it's entirely all her call
but I do think the special effects are
gonna be different going forward because
we are entering another uh patch of of
dryness for work and I also think there
is a uh an awareness at the plight of
visual effects artists that is more
public so I hopefully they're gonna get
some more uh some more love going
forward as the writers need to as well
absolutely so if you if you know a
writer give them a hug and uh yeah they
need it Jeff Carroll back again let's
let's get also Jeff Carroll in the live
chat said we Googled the wrong guides
Danny love this is Danny love and I
thought that was worth noting uh let's
fix that my bad oh this guy looks way
more like static shock definitely okay
I've probably I feel like I've made I've
seen this I've seen this guy that's so
funny
the shots went from like he's now stoic
and looks like an actor and the other
guy was like I'm a nice guy you want to
meet me at the beach like this is this
really buddy dude he was on Keenan the
hit show starring Keenan as well this
guy actually looks a bit like Caleb
McLachlan which is funny yeah there you
go you gotta there you go let's let's
get a little headshot on the screen so
you guys can see there you go there's
there's your boy there's a boy right
there yeah that'll always work
he's up and coming and I think honestly
for a lot of these characters I think
that's that's another thing is uh Hey
shouts out to Bucky Barnes holding it
down moderating the chat but yeah I feel
like it's it's a delicate dance of when
you want somebody with a built up
profile versus somebody with uh you know
that up and coming you know hunger also
as we get back to Jeff Carl sorry very
quickly the visual effects thing is also
really tricky because every single movie
in the Marvel Pantheon as well as most
movies that aren't like just you know
five million dramas are so visual
effects heavy now and visual effects
artists work is only noticed when it's
not Peak there are so many shots that
are visual effects there are so many
moments that people don't realize are
some people say bad visual effects
they're really denigrating hundreds of
hours of great work they don't even
realize because it's seamless so I I do
think it's going to change I just think
we need to get some respect in the names
yeah there there are so many visual
effects you would never realize in fact
like so many of before we hop back this
last Point like so many even just like
skylines backdrops are completely
altered completely changed buildings are
dropped and things that you wouldn't
ever expect to require any kind of CGI
I'm in Rome right now John's in
California yes we visual effects really
worked on our green screen setup for
this live stream today uh Jeff Carroll
we're gonna knock out your uh your
two-parter here and then uh mayank
ranavare rananavare has another little
news story we can touch upon uh Jeff
Carroll first though four out of five
love all the Guardians of the Galaxy 3
characters and we love you uh just for
again being so generous with your time
this morning but Lila was my second
favorite only behind rocket her kindness
and joy melted my heart and the heaven
plus quill refusing to let rocket die
scene is a top 10 best MCU moment do you
agree Coy I agree and I also love that
the last thing Rocket says to Lila is
I'm not a raccoon and then he accepts
that he's a raccoon as part of like that
closure so I really like the last moment
of him like he's not ready yet and that
moment really not only showed he wasn't
ready but it also had that connection
and like yeah I'm not a raccoon theme
throughout the three movies and then him
like meeting the raccoons and like
embracing who he was I think that moment
tied to the heaven moment is in my top
five like I really think the rocket Arc
is one of the most important
self-acceptance arcs and I think that's
what one of the things that draws me to
Comics is a lot of the themes and Comics
are about accepting who you are no
matter what you are and I think that the
rocket portrayal captured that so
beautifully with that heaven scene
absolutely and uh and two I just love
the little nuances of like the Flatline
happens when he finally breathes that
sigh of relief and then he's sucked back
to uh not Earth but you know he sucked
back to life on perhaps the most sort of
down to earth line he could say which is
I'm not a raccoon you know like yeah
it's the most sort of like rocket on the
Mortal plane line to do that with that
also suits the theme so very well and uh
yeah absolutely a top MCU sequence just
like so like that movie is is stuck I
have not seen it second time because I
left and I've been I've been trying to
move my schedule to see it a second time
I haven't done that for a Marvel movie
in a while like where I'm like I have to
change everything yeah I've said I've
seen it Thrice now and I would happily
see it again uh oh dude I'm excited for
you I'm gonna re-watch one and two first
that's why I've been delayed because I
need to set aside like eight hours not
two dude I want to do the whole journey
do the Greg do the yeah one two holiday
three
I need some time oh the end game
Infinity he did Greg went hard Greg went
hard yeah it's just time because that's
what Greg does he goes hard I haven't
even seen the Covenant yet which is
Jakey Jake's and Guy Richie oh dude
you've been up for three weeks that's
your duty that's my I mean those are two
of my favorite creators yeah and and
sishu or what's the what's the John Wick
uh like killing Nazis movie oh I haven't
seen that either it's killing me I'm
doing one of those today actually when I
leave here
well you report back I'll let you live
stream and let us know how your Cinema
journey is going and then between now
and then Guardians all and then think
about this until the end of the stream
what Marvel should guy Richie direct or
DC uh but we already kind of I think DC
would be easier Constantine oh
cut the check cut the check Jeff Carroll
any thoughts on who Matthew McFadden is
playing in Deadpool 3 he's incredible in
succession I am glad that dude is
starting to get his flowers because uh
because he's an actor I've been aware of
uh I think my sister introduced me to
him like years and years ago from like
British Telly and uh and yeah like his
crossover has been really fun to watch
uh much love to you
Jeff Carroll and uh and Greg sends his
love as well he's just in the Next Room
he's he's hard away he's hard away
working and he appreciates you as well
and we appreciate your time can we look
up this uh Matthew McFadden oh sure yeah
well you're not a succession guy aren't
you
dude there's only so many hours in the
day koi just only watch TV that's all
only watch TV oh the guy with the
handsome I like his little Windswept
look there in that one photo with his
billing shirt here he is um I see this
man as some sort of uh there's an
evilness
he can yeah I mean he I feel like when I
see him play sympathetic characters he
can be Charming but I associate him a
bit more with stoicism but then when
he's playing evil he can be quite like a
conniving sort of Personality as a
character I was like and certainly on
the bits of succession I have seen he is
like a a complete you know manipulator
yeah he's definitely like a lothario in
the in the you know mutt drop era like I
see him as like you know a handsome oh
it was Mr Darcy he's literally like
handsome uh I see him now though is like
maybe someone working for
um someone trying to get the mutants
like he definitely like has that
business Wolverine obviously wolverine
look at the bunch look at those chops uh
I think he's gonna be working for like a
department some sort of evil
conglomerate trying to get mutants in it
because they're going to be so much
story to tell they're gonna have to have
like an evil
you don't need evil you need Evil all
right while he kills the Fox University
fine
all right mayank run on a Vare how's it
going thank you for your generous
contribution and uh mayank says Hey koi
and John hello to you with all episodes
of echo dropping on November 29th you
think the MCU fans are ready to binge
watch episodes instead of waiting every
week
I mean I think the prospect of MC of
like bingeable MCU is certainly
something that people will take
advantage of regardless uh I don't know
I'm very curious to see how this uh
supports or detracts from you know the
show itself Echo being their sort of
trial balloon for this and I know that
there's a lot of speculation that this
simply means that they don't really have
much faith in it and they just want to
get it out of the way uh I would like to
believe that maybe there's a value in
trying with a less you know uh
consequential show or less you know
Flagship show trying an alternate
release strategy
um
but yeah I don't know I'm very curious
because it does suggest to me perhaps
that you know there have been bumps in
the road of the Disney Plus shows and
I'm sure that retention can be a part of
that when you have you know a show as
controversial say as She-Hulk which I
enjoyed but you know certainly a lot of
people probably dropped off of from week
to week and maybe rage quit or whatever
else I don't feel like Echo would really
be the most controversial show they
would have but uh I'm curious I think
fans would would absolutely eat up the
binge though I think it comes out in a
very interesting time uh we're having
all of the secret Invasion rapping about
a week before it if scheduling is like
right sorry you said rapping
now I connected uh so if if that uh
wraps right before this show and
November 10th is the Marvels to me this
is them getting all of the things that
were in production before the biggest
like I shift out at once I'm really
looking at it as I like okay Fresh Start
2024 I think secret invasion is going to
be incredible I think the Marvels has
had some time to cook and percolate and
I think it's going to be great because
you need a cost of fan I haven't heard
enough about this show to know what
they've been able to reconfigure so I
see this as like a one shot like in
comic books you've got miniseries you've
got ongoing series you've also got one
shots them releasing it once feels like
a one shot to me where this is gonna be
a week of press versus six or seven or
eight weeks of press and
the problem with this show is that we
already know Daredevil and Kingpin are
in it so all the Press around it no
matter what is gonna be durable and
Kingpin so now they get the same one
week of their own King compressed as
they would have before but they're done
and clean for the beginning of the next
year so I see it as like a calculated
experiment I think um
I think binge culture is very
detrimental to Art I think it's very uh
unhealthy to both the consumer and the
Creator if you put two years of work
into something and then people watch it
in the background for six hours and then
talk about it for a day that's very
unhealthy for the way we receive uh
stimuli as people and the way that we
perceive uh Commerce I think it's very
detrimental to society so I don't love
it but um that's a bigger conversation
a much bigger
koi's comment Corner hates capitalism
that's the next time
join us for the brand new series The
Death of Art uh Francesco Imperial thank
you for the moment of silence we do
appreciate your generosity there and
let's do one more Super Chat before we
hop into another one of our featured
news stories that I don't think has been
asked about just yet uh but let's do mad
of all trades Feist what would your top
character to lead the MCU what would be
your top character to leave the MCU
going forward I like Tony Stark uh sorry
like Tony Stark was for a time love you
guys over here 10 of us watching damn
party on a Saturday to all 10 of you
that's crazy that's so cool I feel like
powerful knowing there's even 10 people
total watching I'm humbled yeah like
always forget people watch this I just
feel like we're yelling into the void
these answers then I find out 10 people
are one one name the power uh I think
that leading the MCU going forward
um should kind of like a an X-Men golden
blue situation like I'd love if it was
like you know this little section this
little section I think this street level
stuff is going to be very like Daredevil
LED like and maybe not even him as a
leader but I think there's going to be
like a subsect of Street I think as far
as Avengers stuff I think we've got a
lot of like contenders right I think
Haley Steinfeld leading a Young Avengers
would be really interesting I I think
that'd be a really fun way to have
because she's like charm incarnate it'd
be fun to have someone that's like that
human element I think as far as the
Avengers go I think Anthony Mackey is
pretty poised to do that with cap four I
think him getting that movie and like
setting himself up as a leader is going
to be great his speech at the end of
Falcon Winter Soldier was genius
um I don't I've never seen Doctor
Strange as that guy and I feel like they
started that path and they kind of gave
up on it so I'm really curious right
we're at a big Crux
a Crux a horcrux yeah that's where he is
also I saw uh while we're adjusting uh
in the live chat the regular live chat
said um uh who who has characters that
can take on Marvel or DC like what comic
company and why can't people invent new
characters that is people new characters
every like month there's like tons like
Berserker outsold Marvel in DC for a
time that's a new character uh something
is killing the children from boom
Studios one of the top selling Comics
all the time uh lots of stuff coming out
of image like sagas new characters from
like the last five years uh there's like
there's constantly new characters and
movies are getting made of them but
people aren't like David Fincher is
directing a comic book movie this year
but he's not advertising in his comic
book movie there's a movie called The
Killer that nobody's talking about yet
because it's in November that is a
French comic that is not Marvel or DC
and it's a Fincher movie so I think it's
very close-minded to think that the only
thing is coming out of these houses
because that's like patently Andrew
what do you mean koi falsehoods
falsehoods on the internet people saying
things with periods when it should be
ellipses or question marks oh golly well
really quick and in fact talking about
not periods but maybe commas uh we do
have some box office projections for The
Flash movie everybody's got eyes on
flash because obviously the controversy
obviously it has great Word of Mouth
despite that controversy and it's at a
fulcrum point for the DCU moving forward
so it's got a a big set of shoes to fill
and it's also coming on the heels of two
pretty
uh Rocky openings in uh Shazam Fury of
the Gods and Black Adam uh both
underperforming to one degree or another
uh so the big question is will the flash
succeed or Flop and we have the early
box office projections reading here off
the direct who uh is sharing box office
Pros first box office projections how
many times can you say box office in one
sentence and also projections like guys
come on yeah the source is right there
you could say that five times
Productions but the uh the current
estimated opening weekend uh for for
domestic for the US is somewhere uh
reported between 115 million and 140
million and the total projection for the
domestic box office is said to be around
280 to 375 million
um which you know if it does hit that
115 to 140 million uh you know you're
looking close to the top three of
opening weekends for the DC uh
eat you at the time now becoming the DCU
the top one being Batman v Superman at
166 million followed by Suicide Squad at
133 Man of Steel at 116.
um and then the top grosses if it
manages to hit that 280 to uh 375
million mark would put it uh I mean you
know Man of Steel is at the bottom of
their little list here they have Wonder
Woman at 412 million Aquaman at 335 dawn
of Justice at 3 30 Suicide Squad at 325
in Man of Steel at 291 so they're not
expecting this necessarily to cap out uh
ahead of you know all of those but
there's certainly a possibility that it
could cap out pretty big what do you
think how do you think it's going to do
I think it's going to do exceptionally
and I think it's really interesting to
look at a movie like Batman versus
Superman the two biggest comic book
names in history like so Spider-Man's
like right there between them like in
the top three it's those three uh I
didn't realize it opened that strong and
then the Dropout was that bananas like
it literally only made its opening
weekend again like if you look at its
166 was the opening and then it left at
3 30. it literally just made like it had
three days and then the rest of it's
running really made that much again so I
think uh flash being a less known name
than Batman and doing as well as it's
going to do is very impressive obviously
they put Batman front and center in the
marketing it's very like you know parent
they're leaning into that but yeah
having a Flash movie uh you know that's
been in production for four years open
that strong would be great for DC uh
it's clearly part of the reason why they
haven't really commented on where that
character is going to go next
um I think DC
I want them to have a huge win because I
want the I want the momentum going into
the DCU to be strong so I hope people
show up like this looks like they will
I'm personally very excited for it um I
think it looks stunning so please 200
million dollar opening
all right let's hop back into some super
chats appreciate that from uh appreciate
your expertise there
I'll check streamlabs too we haven't
done those yet uh yeah let's let's uh
let's while we're while we're
gallivanting yeah let's uh let's do uh
one more Super Chat and then we'll hop
over and take a look at uh the stream
Labs here just keep things flowing
um
yeah we got that man of all trades and
then uh
okay let's Deadshot is next sorry just
orienting here
um
and uh did you guys hear thank you so
much Deadshot really appreciate your
contribution did you guys hear the rumor
plot of Deadpool 3 with them having to
kill a variant Magneto also John are you
and Greg gonna react to the Mortal
Kombat 1 game trailer I feel like that
probably would have happened already
there's been so much other stuff going
on and I know Greg has had his hands
entirely full with a bunch of different
things so um
Never Say Never but likely not at the
moment but koi have you heard about this
Deadpool 3 plot rumor they're gonna kill
variant Magneto I think uh they're gonna
kill a lot of variants because I have
been saying for six years it's got to be
Deadpool kills the fox Universe he knows
in the fox Universe Magneto yeah I think
that rumor totally tracks because uh it
is part of my big Theory I think it'd be
a great focal point if they had like a
singular you know fixture in Magneto
like I'd love to have a a versus Magneto
finale for The Fox Universe uh I also
think that uh they're gonna be meeting a
lot of wolverines I think Hugh Jackman
is gonna play like a bevy of wolverines
because I think that'd be a big draw for
him to go back so I'd love to see like a
lot of wolverines and a lot of magnetos
and a lot of the characters we know well
but I ultimately would just really love
to see Deadpool have to clean up
continuity I think it'd be so funny to
see like the fox merger B exemplified
through a character that knows he breaks
the fourth wall taking out these
characters so I do think this is coming
and I also think we're gonna get a lot
of characters that Marvel would never
use uh in the movie so I'm sure it's my
most anticipated movie after
spider-verse drops next in two weeks
okay like spider versus in two weeks
and uh then it becomes all about
Deadpool 3 for me absolutely let's move
on over and see who we got on the stream
Labs we do not have any yet oh perfect
well now we've called it out but uh the
link is pinned just in case you uh you
want to uh jump in over there Reyes cast
you as thing Greg is read and Mia's
torch by the way oh oh that's good I
like that I like that casting quite a
bit I uh I was gonna about to say I ship
us but that's not how that word works
well that'd be like you as soon me as
read or maybe me as soon you was reading
could be you're more of a read
especially like to get the Look hair
going oh yeah yeah you've begun your
wisdom uh is that what we call that oh
that is definitely when it's by the
temples that's where your smarts are oh
that's why I feel good you know he's got
that wisdom thanks you're showing it
externally I do my best to Kenneth
Estrella uh if and thank you for joining
us for uh for your generous contribution
if you had the chance to cast each other
in both an MCU and TCU Ruby Who Would
You cast each other as
oh man that's a really funny timing yeah
I was gonna say ah I mean I feel like
the chat might have taken care of it no
no we got this I mean I would cast koi
oh oh man you remember that stripper guy
who got to be Dr Fate in uh in Suicide
Squad hell to pay that's who I would
cast you as she got the little ankh
[__] stamp just like getting in there
and being naked yeah and I get an oncram
Stam I'm in okay I'm signing the
paperwork steel or whatever I don't even
know how much the rate is but I'm in uh
I'm gonna go for MCU let's do one each
uh and then go back uh MCU
um you don't have the I know people are
very specific about ethnicity and I
respect that I appreciate I do think
representation is important but in this
moment he's so perfect for it I gotta go
there I think he'd be a good Forge Forge
he's a mutants with the power to invent
anything he thinks of I would love that
so basically like he's a guy that's
mutant ability is to create he's pure
creation and you're always doing like
you're on your phone you're on your
laptop you're running all these things
so like I think it'd be look at you dude
I would be down so like awesome you got
a thing with storm so good for you so
yeah
I know there's like uh you know a
background in Canon that doesn't work
for like his history like ethnicity but
I think John would be an excellent Forge
thank you and then DC wise I'm never
gonna have as good of a pick for for you
well it's hard I read some comics and
you read some Comics but like I really
I've read a few more uh and then DC wise
uh people are excited about the story
see one people are excited about the
stripper pull
um let's see let's see you're my Mr
mix-up little lick
who would you be at DC I think it'd be
you'd be a fun plastic man I'll do it
plastic that'd be a lot of fun like a
really manic high energy like you want
enough G fuel in Starbucks sure that'd
be fun sure sure I'm down for that I'm
absolutely down for that those are my
poles you got any Marvel pull
um
you know what man
I just want to cast you as both
Wolverine and cyclops for some reason oh
okay I'm into that I don't know why I'll
be both I feel like some for some reason
those characters just come to mind when
I think of you in an MCU yeah because
you know you're like buffered by the day
and yeah you're a bit like on the on the
more compact but also just like thicked
outside see a green arrow as well I like
that thicked out green arrow into it and
uh Forge in the storm of Claremont run I
totally agree and and also if not John I
think pitcher Pascal will be a great
forger oh any casting Arrangement that I
can share with Pedro Pascal is a good
one in my book uh but yeah
that was fun I like that question I like
that question too and I'm gonna be now
you got reading to do yeah now I'm gonna
be thinking because I'm like I want to
come up with a less basic choice for uh
for koi next time because I feel so
flattered with like the cool pools you
just gave me so damn and now I've got I
got a new character to do I'm excited uh
Mikey Cheers Cheers mcgears uh
you shorted my brain now that's how
happy I am to see you in this live chat
right now let's just put it out into the
universe we need a good Brainiac movie I
would settle for an Easter egg or end
credit scene
Brainiac I think Brainiac was about to
be the villain in every Superman movie
like I feel like since since Superman
they've been like what about Brainiac uh
I think I pitched this on one of my
koi's comic Corners uh I think the DC
announcement one what I would do with
Brainiac is I would have the
juxtaposition of Brainiac as the least
human thing show the humanity of
Superman so I'd use Brainiac in movie
two and I'd I'd set him up as a
post-credits scene and then in the
second movie you have Superman
introduced you don't have an origin but
you do have you have a lot of
introductions so you've got Daily Planet
you've got the whole new cast you got
all those things so I'd have a villain
that was like you know like a mid-level
villain I wouldn't use a big bad here
and I'd I'd want a kind of like um I
think Red Skull was wasted because they
used him in the first one like I want
someone that is you know serviceable for
the story but then in the second movie
to lean into the humanity about Superman
is have Brainiac be
um a representation of AI have him
represent what it is that we're choosing
in our regular life like we're currently
choosing not not to use AI to make a
basic Universal income we're choosing to
make AI make art which is ignorant the
only thing that makes us different from
animals is our opposable thumbs and art
like we actually create emotion we
create something that when you see it
you connect to it emotionally you see
these characters and you go man I have a
feeling towards that whether it's you
love them or hate them you you feel
compelled because of Art and art can be
anything that makes you feel it can be
music it can be movies it can be uh
painting it can be anything that causes
emotion and instead of making Humanity
better and making Society better we as
humans have decided to make this hyper
intelligence that we've created over
time the thing taking away people's jobs
and taking away creativity and currently
in town right now we're deciding the
suits are deciding to let writers who
pour their heart into creativity who
open their souls who become a wound for
you to share this art we're going no no
we don't need to pay them more we need
to make sure the people at the top that
are causing these problems get paid more
so I would have Brainiac represent greed
I would have him represent the way that
we as Humanity fail to make Humanity
better we systemically cause our own
problems and I feel like Brainiac
perfectly juxtaposes Superman wanting
the best for Humanity even though he's
not human there's no more human
character than Superman and he's what we
should look to become he should be what
we aspire to be what should we not
aspire to be is is the loss of art
through AI so I'd love Brainiac as an AI
character in the second film once we
have an established Superman and I think
it's the right time for it because we're
running towards [__] yeah
that sounds like the name of like a
biography
or some kind of like you know rumination
on on I don't know it's my album so
serious
yeah yeah it's like one of those new
edgy books about how to like get control
of your finances or something yeah it's
like my self-help book like my my Tony
Robbins running towards [__]
you heard it here lean out of the chat
koi oh that's why we moved me yeah I
thought I thought you were suddenly
telling me to stop talking and then I
saw you yeah
boy uh no just just double checking to
make sure that this has not come up yet
gonna do another little news story uh
before we hop back into the chats
um but yeah Jonathan Majors is uh they
just released both information about the
Loki season two plot uh that included
some you know noted cast members as well
as uh quantumania has been released uh
on Disney plus and all of those have
come with uh no mention of Kang or
Jonathan majors in the process leading
people to believe that perhaps Marvel is
getting on the you know Road toward
perhaps removing him or recasting him or
or something on the flip side it could
just be that
well I mean with a Quantum Mania it's
really hard to argue uh but with
something like Loki season two is you
could certainly argue as many people
have already put forth that you know
maybe there are multiple people to focus
on throughout the season maybe there are
multiple villain figures maybe like
season one there will be you know an
episodic quality that will not just
solely be focused on big bad Kang Victor
timely Etc
um but I mean it it for both of these to
come out at the same time you do I think
have two sides of a coin because to not
uh mention him or or you know Colony
attention to at least Kang the character
uh you know in promoting the home video
or the home streaming release of
quantumania does seem a little telling
and granted we are just in the thick of
you know the trial having started and I
think they've only had one actual court
appearance as of now so nobody really
knows where that's gonna wind up but uh
how are you feeling about this portent
uh you know the Kang thing is
interesting especially with uh Jeff
loveness uh
however that happened
um I do think it's really interesting
that we set up Kang in a much better way
in Loki like I think Kang and Loki was
much more interesting I've said it many
times and I think that Jonathan Majors
really understands Kang I think Jonathan
majors made a very good Kang movie
Somewhere in Ant-Man yeah like his his
moment so I honestly like obviously I
don't know the the actual thing that
happened every time I've talked about it
on record I've been very clear that
until I know what it is I will not be
someone profiting off of uh drama like
people that made house money off of
Johnny Depp I never heard but I do think
it's a really messy situation for Marvel
and I think that they have to handle it
as distantly as they can until they know
what it is like I think they're being
very smart to not make a statement I
think they're being very smart to go
like hey we have to prove something
happened here so um taking his name off
is a a very
big small statement like it's a very
like whoa but also like what else are
you gonna do so I think it's uh there's
a no-win scenario happening in real time
between the strike between the way the
box office has gone between the way
people are shifting how they consume art
between the way people are consuming
content like in general I I don't know
if the Disney model is going to work
that long and they have to change a lot
of things so that with their lead actor
for this phase it's a mess so I I see
why they did it I just I feel like it's
not fair to comment on the future until
we know what it is yeah yeah I would
agree with that most certainly uh let's
hop on back to our super chats over here
um and what do you guys think I mean
obviously everyone is just sort of I
think waiting with a certain amount of
baited breath for whatever uh you know
is sort of realized in uh you know the
the proceedings of the case as it
unfolds but I don't know you know it's
like it's so I don't know also someone
when you're removing a thing said uh koi
is not that deep I think art should be
deeper like if you want boring linear
[__] color a coloring book but like
uh these are our myths these are our
lore so our moral compass come from
these stories so it should be deep and
you can read into or not into whatever
you want if you want just people
punching each other that's how you can
see the story but you could also look
into the story and actually like make
your life better or again you can color
I'm good who needs to make life better
AI who who
this guy wants that eight eye riding
because that's what he's looking for
sure Christopher wamhoff we love you
buddy thank you for the moment of
silence in fact uh uh we gave you a
pretty uh good shout out just recently
in fact so keep a lookout for that my
dude what movie was that what we should
keep an eye out for you Chris that's
right oh in fact you should be able to
see oh very specifically for tomorrow if
the schedule holds so uh yeah keep an
eye out for your shout out Chris and uh
we love you much Chris is one of the
best people
not just at the patreon just in life uh
he's out there doing what I like to call
the Lord's work nobody else calls
anything that no original phrase but me
I came up with that I originated it
Jordan Garza thank you so much for being
with us on the stream today I feel like
the chance of Poulter as Jimmy Olsen is
way more than people think especially
with gun using previously worked with
actors he could definitely nail it and I
believe James Gunn has said that uh at
least one character has been cast
although I I perhaps doubt it would be
any of the most notable characters
um but what do you think what do you
think of uh I mean I could certainly see
Will Poulter like you know uh where The
Millers will pulterers Jimmy Olsen like
I definitely I did a fan cast of uh when
everybody was complaining about him
using his wife I put out a video of like
all the Guardians in DC and I was like
this is the future and Will Poulter was
my Olsen uh I think that like of anyone
he's the most directly nearly
appropriate
um I also think he's the right age I
think all of that really works
especially if they're going it's like a
30 Superman I always saw you know Jimmy
and him is about the same age I think
he'd be amazing I also like yeah he's
like a handsome guy but Jimmy has never
been like not like I it's it's so
perfect to me like I just there's
nothing I would change about will
poulter's Jimmy Olsen like when I look
at him I see Jimmy so uh please
thank you
sorry I just wanted to let you know a
little moment Play Just to let people
kind of soak in your feedback and uh and
you know give a Moment of Zen before we
move presents okay but uh but yeah nah
Jimmy Olsen man perfect Justice for
Jimmy I feel like like sometimes you get
shot in the face sometimes you get a
Trilogy I know and we've seen that uh
like we just saw what was that Death of
Superman dude they're such a good
Superman I mean they're such a good
Jimmy Olsen comic called uh Superman's
best best pal Jimmy Olsen and it's a 12
issue miniseries by Matt fraction the
guy that did uh oh yeah the Hawkeye the
Hawkeye run and sex that's the Love talk
dude it's so good his sex criminals and
his Jimmy Olsen are two of my favorite
Comics last five years highly recommend
now when's the crossover happening Jimmy
Olsen sex criminal yeah
what are you doing with that will
Pulitzer get after put the camera down
Jimmy Rocky 67 thank you so much for
hopping into the stream Labs we
appreciate you if you guys uh anywhere
you guys choose to contribute is very
much appreciated all of it helps the
cause but uh just in case you missed it
uh it is in the pinned comment and they
do take a significantly smaller
percentage uh of your contribution than
YouTube does uh not that you know
YouTube uh you know doesn't deserve a
little bit but uh at the same time they
take a lot
so uh very much appreciate you and uh
yeah if uh Rocky 67 asks if Disney left
Florida completely
then what would be your choice for the
best way to cinematically blow up the
existing knee part as part of filming
for Deadpool 4 gets my vote so far you
uh so funny
like that's a great call that may be the
best call for me I would want to do
something that's like uh this is the end
or something where it's like you get
some kind of weird meta comedy where
it's like you know a bunch of people go
into Disney World maybe even embrace the
idea that like they're closing it so we
gotta go one more time and then yeah
have them try to like live through like
a volcano opening up under it or
something I want to go horror movie I
want like a uh uh It's a Small World
After All dystopian commentary like
Fantasia but live action oh I want like
a a really hyper psychedelic trip of the
fall of nostalgia like we're living in a
Nostalgia cage right now like we're
we're all traumatized as a culture so
we're looking to before the trauma to
make us feel better about ourselves and
get that serotonin and dopamine pump so
I'd use it as a way to like look at what
we've made uh Nostalgia and weaponize it
so the death of Disney World
representing the death of Innocence so
I'd like I have a horror movie about
like the loss of of uh belief in
ourselves to create new art and destroy
the park thematically dude I love that
I've never seen it but uh have you ever
seen
oh what is that movie called uh I can
see the poster it's got like a black and
white Mickey hand oh yeah that was like
that documentary yeah stole all the
shots in and it's like some kind of acid
trip Disneyland movie it would be like
I've never seen it but backwards yeah
with sorrow yeah with more sorrow and
destruction I I think that would be the
way to go uh but hey guys I want
everybody in the chat to uh weigh in on
this what would be your Disney World
Destruction movie and uh and how much of
Florida falls into the ocean with it
leave your thoughts shouts out to all
our Florida viewers I know it's got to
be weird living in Florida man like I
don't know it seems like everyone's
always looking at looking at and talking
about Florida for all different reasons
most of them not great but uh I'm sure
you're great but man your your state get
some press Shay Shay thank you for
joining us over here on the stream labs
and in the Stream in general we
appreciate GH very much and as Shea says
one of two comments here I think I am
one of the many getting extremely
impatient with the MCU taking their
sweet time with the introduction of
mutants
foreign
yes one of many sorry for a second I was
like you're not the only one but uh but
yes how kind do you actually think it
will be for Kevin feige how long I think
it was what it was meant to be uh do you
actually think it will be before Kevin
feige gives us at least one freaking
mutant and Kamala Khan does not count
we'll address that before moving on to
your next question
um I mean
I feel like part of it is a contractual
thing I think they've said they can't do
any of the fox at least X-Men characters
or use certain terminology until what
2025 or something like that I think
Deadpool 3 is going to have a lot of
mutants for you yeah it's like they have
to that when they did the whole
Illuminati scene and the Ralph boner
stuff I I sort of remember that being
part of it is it's like it's the rights
that you can't I think recast or you
know have new iterations of those
characters until 2025 yeah there's so
navigation of of legal that's also
causing it yeah so but but I mean you
know certainly uh I think when they do
the good thing is it allows them to
build this like maximum anticipation and
you know 20 I don't know exactly how
rights like these work if it's like if
it's you can't start writing about or
shooting
scenes involving those characters until
2025 or is it just you can't release
something but I feel like you know we're
we're part we're almost halfway through
2023 now so like what happened yeah I
think that was a good place to start it
in Mass but I also think characters
we've met are going to be revealed to be
mutants and Kamala Khan totally does
count she like had an entire show about
it so that's like they not only had the
show but they had the score for the
X-Men show play during it the X-Men
animated series is coming out that's
going to be Canon to the old X-Men
animated series like mutants are here
and I think the long game is smart we
didn't start with the Avengers that was
the DC problem like you've got to earn
it so like I also think that what I
would do is I would have the X-Men be
basically The Avengers going forward
after Secret Wars I'd have the X-Men and
Fantastic Four be the the centerpieces
of the MCU so I think earn that just
like we did with the Avengers um I like
the long game and I like Kamala as the
first meeting absolutely and for this
universe I think that's a nice way to
you know obviously you're you're
shifting a character to some extent but
also yeah you're you're putting this
universe's stamp on the introduction of
mutants yeah so and Raymond has a great
Point Neymar's mutant like we have
mutants
my dude
um let's put some more but just not not
anyone in particular here you guys seem
all like respectfully folks but put some
more respect on the more Namor Shea goes
on to ask and say uh now the Titans is
done wouldn't Anna Diop make a stellar
storm in the MCU her voice her look that
beautiful skin chef's kiss I haven't
seen much of Titans I remember I just
remember that uh that Infamous trailer
with the infamous line uh but what do
you think koi what do you think Titans
was not for me so I don't know at all uh
I don't know her work because I didn't
watch Titans
um I really can't I I I've seen us but I
don't I don't remember uh anything like
Stormy in that um but I I if you like it
I believe you I just can't speak got it
because I don't know where work uh I
just I want someone that can carry a
solo movie because I think storm
deserves an origin film and I think that
she should be introduced like in either
a special edition like World by night
and then get I want all of the leading
X-Men to get their own special or
feature and then become a team so as
long as she's strong enough to carry you
know a franchise then I'm all for
whoever gets cast a storm she looks cool
yeah I just didn't watch Titans I could
certainly see I mean just just yeah
going off look alone I don't I don't
know if I would have knowingly seen her
either I feel like a lot of the things
she's been there things that I've missed
yeah a lot of teams on it and I'll catch
up on but certainly I mean you know I
could easily I'm already imagining
somebody's you know Photoshop of her oh
yeah I'm sure she's been uh cast and I
mean you know having that experience
with Titans certainly bodes you know in
her February for uh playing a role like
that um so yeah I support your pick uh
Here and Now Shay so you know you got it
me at least you got a friend in me
yeah if the road looks rough ahead and
your miles and your miles from your nice
warm bed you know you just remember what
your old pal said all right you got a
friend she could play storm
uh Jordan Garza we did you but uh we
love you anyway just the same uh here we
go let's see
Denisha Lane let's see what you got to
say hey everyone I'm new and just subbed
happy Saturday thank you so much for
being here and for subscribing to the
channel and uh Hey if you could all
leave a like as well on the stream that
helps us out a huge amount but thank you
for being here thank you for spending
your Saturday morning with us you could
be any number of places and we're glad
that you're here and uh and yeah keep
those good old news stories coming
nether 22. how's it going Frank good to
see you from over on the patreon very
much love to you Joshua stradowski and
Harris Dickinson are my soups now
they're just making up names these
aren't names what is people these are
not gonna be talking about my name is
Coy and I'm judging yeah I've never
heard these people Harris Dickinson was
in uh uh the king's man among other
things he was the leader oh that guy
yeah yeah yeah so yeah so I mean
certainly I could see uh some some
soupishness I mean now that's a Superman
chin yeah yeah yeah and I mean you know
you can make his hair a little darker or
whatever but I can see it and again like
in this picture he's a little maybe on
the skinny side for what I imagine
Superman but any skinny person you know
in Hollywood that's some vascularity in
the neck he's definitely got some he's
got some weight on him your neck gets
wider once he has to carry all the blood
to the trunk so that's that's a man
working out sure sure absolutely most
certainly and then who'd you also say uh
Joshua stradowski this is a name yeah
also a person that I have not seen but
there's the face
there's the face right there this is
always getting credits we know I don't
know this man this guy who just found
him on the street yeah there's no
credits whatsoever let's see Justin
Wheel of Time
and that's good I mean like that's the
other thing too is like as much as uh as
much as it is sort of like okay who are
all these people at the same time I
think that's a good thing for a
character like a Superman because I
think you want that character to feel
like we're all just meeting him for the
first time and even though Henry Cavill
had done other things by the time he
became Superman that was certainly my
introduction to him and that I've seen
him before it wasn't a household name
where I was like associating like I said
like that Greek thing and like you know
I just didn't lock him in I feel like
that's as much like big notoriety as you
want is the kind of guy where you are
you see their face and you go oh okay
I've seen him in this thing or that
thing and then yeah you know you you
still have to kind of be reminded you
know once you really solidify somebody
in your head unless you're like a you
know unless you're one of those people
like me who who will like find random
actors and then fixate on them but yeah
uh some solid calls here what do you
guys think in the chat are you in for
either Harris dickison Dickinson or
Joshua Joshua uh no it is Joshua okay
there you go sorry names man names are
hard uh what do you think of those picks
leave it in the chat below Alma pow
thank you so much for joining us and for
contributing to the convo blind spotting
the movie was made down the street from
my house in the bay I want David in the
MCU I do too and when it happens I want
him to do a clipping song for whatever
movie that is just to take things into a
real dark place dude that double album
for the blind potting blind spotting
soundtrack is some of the best like work
like Roth is so good on it he's so good
on it like if he digs is just genius and
blind spotting is such a great movie
love that you're from the bay dude
absolutely
sending love up that way and I'm gonna
think of you Alma as I watch the film
finally and uh cross that off my bucket
list Francesco Imperial what about on a
day armist and also thank you by the way
I just don't want you to feel taken for
granted uh what do you think about anode
armis as a Wonder Woman or Wonder Woman
multiples uh I feel she would be an
excellent casting
small
this is a little small she reads petite
I could I could get past that but I get
what you're saying I think Wonder Woman
is like Amazonian like she's like big
you know like that's a great point
though it should be pretty yeah I don't
know
to me like I think she'd be an
incredible Zatanna like I think that's
there but I I just I picture someone
like
standing next to Superman and like
having not a disparity like there's got
it like that presence of I don't know I
just I I don't think there's a lot of
roles for like statuesque tall jacked
women and I wouldn't want to take that
from one yeah and I mean on a day armist
for me is I I have kind of reached a
critical mass with her where I I'm I
like on a day armist certainly she
always turns in a good performance and
seems very game for the physicality of a
lot of the roles that she chooses but
also I'm just I'm just so used to seeing
her face and hearing her name pitched as
kind of everything right now that it's
hard for me to get super excited but I
could see it and uh and yeah I'm at that
point with her where I'm like I want to
be surprised by or by the casting rather
than go oh yeah that works yeah you know
I think Arya honia is more that but also
more unknown and I think that I don't
know I wanna I'd also see I'd love to
see an unknown I'd love to see someone
new
absolutely
um we've talked a little bit about uh
the high evolutionary
but there is another piece of
information here
um because we talked about him earlier
on in the Stream but James Gunn has
since revealed
um that let me see if I can pull this
tweet up I have it on the Telly
um but yeah James Gunn has sort of
discussed Rocket's choice to spare him
as well as potentially that he has not
actually perished within me I saw that I
like that let me reorder oh yeah you
want to take this away uh yeah so
basically James Gunn revealed on a tweet
uh responding to a new story that high
evolutionary was in fact carried out by
Drax so there is a little uh I guess
that counts as an Easter egg there's a
little a tidbit of movie A lot of people
didn't catch on to that he did survive
so one I think that does translate to
the Arc of Drax he went from Destroyer
to Dad two it shows that rocket saving
him wasn't just for the minute until the
ship blew up uh but I also think it is
an interesting uh moment for Marvel not
just having a one-off Villain Like I
know the beginning of of Marvel there
was a big problem with them like
introducing these great villains and
killing them off I think evolutionary is
a great villain I don't know where I'd
want to see him back because I think
he's specifically good for the guardians
but I do like the fact that uh High
evolutionary is still out there
somewhere because I do think he crushed
it well and I've feel like that could
also too land some Credence I don't know
I mean certainly in the wake of
Guardians 3 and the Jonathan Majors
controversy people have been you know
speculating well hey you know you could
easily
find some mumbo-jumbo way of rewriting
history and making it so the high
evolutionary is is a Kang variant and
then he could take over as Kang or
something like that which I mean him you
know continuing on could be some sort of
I don't know means of
um
you know I don't know like him still
being out there could be some means of
legitimizing that or something I think
it's so hard to combine two characters
that are already established I mean I'm
sure there is some some way to do it
it's just I I had to be written really
well to not feel like it was like we
that written to a corner what do we do
yeah uh but I mean the acting is there I
would love to see you know him him
portray more I just Kang is so specific
I've seen people be like Mega the Doom
Dynasty there's a multiversal element at
play here that like yeah Doom's got
magic but it's not time and time is
going to be such an element for what I
think they're setting up so high
evolutionary doesn't really have a time
element I I don't know I I I want to see
what they do we'll we'll see yeah let me
let me pull up the Tweet here what James
Gunn has said and uh really quick Let's
uh let's
sorry many moving Parts throughout your
Forge that's right man that's that's me
I'm gonna I'm just uh I'm an inventor
over here
um but yeah we got James Gunn saying
basically uh the actual question
oh my God Twitter can be very confusing
sometimes uh yeah he basically said uh
can you Joseph hear somebody uh with the
handle Slither 2006 asks uh can you say
what happened in the high evolutionary
after they saved him
um and James Gunn
uh you know goes on to say that he's
been imprisoned on nowhere but here
let's uh let's readjust for the supers
and then we can also see this tweet here
real quick
um so but yeah I think it's an
interesting Prospect of still having him
around and I think it speaks uh
certainly as James Gunn has said to the
growth and evolution of Rocket as a
character and the empathy uh is
something that he directly pointed out
as being you know like a big part of
that Arc and journey for him in
particular
um but in the man's own words over here
we got let's uh let's
this little smush as well
um yeah there we go
so many moving Parts killing it always
so many things everyone's happy uh yes
so rocket literally says one uh uh one
Tweeter uh writes that uh he wouldn't
kill the high evolutionary and the
Guardians proceed to save everyone uh on
the ship animal in person alike uh James
Gunn says spoiler yes the whole
combination uh uh it's the whole
combination of Rocket's Journey his
shift becomes uh his shifts comes in
that he doesn't kill him he goes from
being the least empathetic to the most
empathetic Guardian it seems silly and
Hollow that he'd refuse to kill him and
then leave him on an exploding ship and
yes there is a deleted scene
it's really great actually but it messed
up the pacing of the end but you'll see
it in the extras eventually and I think
that does also just go to uh you know
solve a bit of an issue that some people
had in terms of you know logic when it
came to that aspect of the movie is you
have this guy who is like so terrible
and and while in the moment I did
appreciate the I I honestly it is funny
like
yeah what do you sacrifice for Flow
versus you know the clarity of the story
and here I mean I appreciate that they
went with flow
um but it does beg that question and I'm
you know kind of glad to know in an
auxiliary sense that yeah that is what
happened and that they at least like
took in prisoner or something like that
well I like that you can go to that cut
scene like you can see Drax carry him
out if you like have him show up another
thing and like it's already filmed then
you can like pop in your Blu-ray be like
oh like I like that it's like a detail
not like shoved in your face and that
there's deleted scene if you want it in
your face yeah I think it worked for me
yeah yeah yeah and I mean you know in
the moment it was only that question of
again like they've killed so many people
to get here
but also I don't know I guess it's the
else the ethical question about you know
when you have you know people forced to
be soldiers what do you do yeah and I do
appreciate that the movie again multiple
times at least acknowledges the the kind
of difficult you know two things
happening at once of that yeah of
especially in that post-credits moment
where they're like don't you feel kind
of bad for these creatures that we have
to you know deal with
um and so you know there's I I've seen
bits picked apart with like you know the
treatment of uh of War Pig and the other
sort of uh uh uh hellspawn yeah and
whatnot but um but yeah I think it is
sort of an interesting and a nice uh
culmination certainly for the character
of Rocket but what do you guys think and
uh and yeah how do you hope the high
evolutionary might return and are you
down for the idea that he could
potentially you know swap out for Kang
if uh if necessary
um and would you I don't know would you
be upset if they did that if they were
like if they had to and they were like
well Chuck is so great and has that
gravitas you know we could just you know
retcon High evolutionary I would rather
see a high evolutionary stay high
evolutionary and come back than have
high evolutionary become the king
personally I just feel like it would
feel
um like they were trapped into doing a
choice instead of just making the choice
they wanted I'd love to see evolutionary
in Secret Wars or you know in another
thing but I I feel like if Jonathan
majors can't be Kang because you know we
find out truths uh then I think that
recasting him is an option because the
Multiverse I also think the Multiverse
is such a tricky thing because like it's
allowing you infinite possibility that
you're just not taking like instead of
making bold swings they're just going
like well sometimes Doctor Strange is
gonna be always played by Benedict
Cumberbatch but then Loki might be
multiple different things and it's like
they need to build their own rules but I
don't feel like they trust uh or maybe
the audiences just can't keep up I I
don't know what's the flaw but uh I do
think that the Kang dynasty was gonna be
the movies we've lived through aren't
all in the same universe I think the
reason we haven't seen the celestial
hand in other things is because that's a
different Multiverse I think they're
very consciously like I think the reason
Spider-Man swung through New York at the
end of his movie in Hawkeye wasn't
involved is a tip of the Hat towards
that being in a different universe so I
think there's going to be elements of
this that we have big epiphanies in in
Kang so you need to have a through line
and I don't know how you do that with
recasting It's Tricky that makes sense
yeah this is a mess man I tried to Vamp
for you I tried no no no the Marvel
thing yeah yeah no this is great now
this this moment here is fine but Marvel
where they are like situations they're
at the Pinnacle of bringing it together
and now it's falling and uh you
mentioned just now doctor strange and uh
we also have another little piece of
casting news
yeah uh chiwa tell edu4 has been cast in
venom he's got the adrenaline momentum
but the question is who will he be
playing and there's not really much
known yet about his involvement
um although Venom three uh apparently is
based off a script that you know uh Tom
Hardy helped come up with the story for
us so you know continuing on that
shepherding but you know there's I think
the obvious question is will he play a
new character to attella gofor or will
he show up as Baron mordo in some way
shape or form and as I mean I am in my
position here and now I'm like please
let's do Baron mordo and you know
something to do with Spider-Man I don't
know but he's here now like yeah I think
that would be very fun but at the same
time I guess I would expect that
uh he's probably gonna play and I even
looked up like who could he be playing
and I was like okay so there's a bunch
of characters that are possible and
rumored none of whom I am an expert on
but but what would you what would you
see for that I think Tom Hardy's
probably done then after three I want
him to fight Spider-Man and if
Spider-Man's in it there's no reason
bear mortal can't be I feel like I don't
know I feel like like a Spider-Man is in
it that makes the case for it possibly
being bare immorto better yeah that's
what I'm thinking it's like I feel like
it's time I feel like he's Venom I I
don't see Tom Hardy playing venom for
like 10 movies I feel like a Trilogy is
a nice beautiful wrap up I feel like
bringing in an MCU Venom in the next
wave of of Spider-Man would be smart uh
I could see like when they bring Tom
Holland back they could do another Venom
because we never actually had the meat
so I would love to have Andrew Garfield
uh you know mix it up and I'd love to
have maybe a variant of Baron mordo like
especially since we now that actually
ties into our last Point Baron mordo was
chewatel in Doctor Strange even though
that was a variant of Baron mordo so
from whatever reason he's another Nexus
being so I can see that actor playing
the baron mortal of that universe and I
and I think that uh Venom needs to fight
Spider-Man finally and I would love to
see that be Baron mordo yeah yeah 100
what do you guys think are you down for
I mean uh Winter Soldier in the chat is
asking how exactly that would work but I
think it more comes down to like if I
think it could easily work if it's just
another mordo variant Doctor Strange was
in a Spider-Man movie it's already like
they already know each other Baron mordo
could literally be a problem for
Spider-Man and he gets sent through a
portal and Lee lands in in the Venom
verse and like there's there's options
yeah yeah absolutely I mean Jen Jacinda
I agreed she would tell a G4 can play
anyone and I too would be happy
um but yeah heart to heart but variants
when they met it was mordo what does
that mean
Kevin Hart Kevin Hart is Baron mordo
into it that's right he's in venom as
well Laura I loved house the dragon uh
actually liked it more than Game of
Thrones really that's well which part of
right there oh no I just think it was I
mean obviously it was more consistent
it's only been one season but uh I felt
like it was very dark and chess playing
like Game of Thrones was but it felt
less malicious to the audience I like it
yes absolutely there was maliciousness
towards each other like there is in that
world they built but it didn't feel like
they were intentionally like you love
this person and like Game of Thrones
always felt like it was mean to me like
I just didn't I didn't enjoy watching it
Game of Thrones is is daring you at all
times yeah and I I found myself I didn't
watch all the Game of Thrones I dipped
in and out so I I prefer and I love Matt
Smith and I think what Matt has done
with like silent acting in that show and
obviously when he speaks but like I
think the casting in that show is
impeccable and I really I was so
impressed absolutely absolutely and I
hope I mean what was it they were saying
like all our scripts are written so
we're good it's actually gonna carry out
yeah but uh I don't know we'll see
hopefully we'll see what this writers
weird times out there guys hopefully
they can still keep mostly nailing and I
know some book fans had had certain
gripes about it but I hope they can keep
nailing it for season two Jaden Voss
thank you for joining us in the super
chats today uh Jaden says I would
definitely love to see Jesse Spencer as
Batman for the DCU along with Noah
schnapp as Damien Wayne
get on the Google machine no no uh no no
a snap most certain things uh let's see
who Jesse Spencer is though okay this
guy I oh oh I know I've seen him and
stuff yeah he was on house that's right
he was like one of the main uh
supporting doctors on House MD alongside
Hugh Laurie and Omar Epps and uh the the
lady on the show whose name I'm blanking
on right now and I feel bad
um interesting interesting interesting
as Batman huh he's like 12. who's this
boy I know and that's the thing is like
I was watching him
as I mean I was watching him on house
you know like a long enough time ago but
he still looks kind of boyish here's him
as a more of a man you know here's his
more recent look so like I could kind of
see that as Bruce Wayne actually when
he's not as in in as much of a boyish
mode
um so yeah not bad actually I wouldn't
have guessed it and I I like that you
know and I haven't thought about him in
a while no it's not being too old for
Damien that's a good question too and I
feel like they're gonna be in an
interesting position with that because
obviously at least I'm sure there are
many different iterations age-wise of
Damien in the comics and in various
meetings but I do feel like going young
is the way to introduce this type of
Batman yeah and I mean from what we've
experienced to the DC animated films it
certainly seems like yeah you you meet
him when he's still a kid or a young
teen and then you get to watch that
because he also got Titans to do and
stuff so I feel like that's the tricky
part is you gotta be able to cast
somebody who like is believably young
but who's also actually young enough
that they can you know grow with that
character they gotta find their hit girl
yeah right like it's it's that casting
so yeah I mean good luck to that cast
director because that's a big role and
that's that too is like that's a
character that uh I have come to really
enjoy and I know like at the outset
James like he's my favorite Robin people
like what
um but I don't know I've come to really
appreciate that character and enjoy that
character so yeah I'm very
it was sort of yeah
I'm curious as to how this is going to
turn out
um but yeah how do you guys feel about
these casting choices a lot of casting
today the casting day it was in the
title Brynn Ashcroft hey John and Coy
hey yourself thank you for being here uh
happy Saturday just want to say hi and
you guys rock you rock and and thank you
for just sharing the love I appreciate
means a lot it's nice I mean like always
appreciate all of the feedback but when
you take a little time just to make us
feel appreciated that just warms my soul
up so uh I appreciate you very much and
thank you for being here with us Sam the
man lee Coy highly recommend Young
Justice personal Peak DC what do you
think I think John and I have 30 more DC
animated films and maybe then uh the
only I mean the only time I've had time
to watch anything has been here uh so uh
maybe I came out 13 years ago and I've
never seen an episode how many six
seasons unlikely but uh wow it's a lot
of Young Justice keep it in the back
pocket how many shows to reopen the show
with going like I haven't had time to
start that I mean I think each of us has
a list that just grows one of my top 10
shows of the last 10 years is Wu-Tang an
American Saga and season three came out
four months ago and I haven't watched it
so there's a literally one of my
favorite shows aired and I missed it
Dave is on I haven't watched any Dave
I'm very behind oh boy but maybe after
we finish all the DC animated films you
were a bad fan the worst but I'm glad
you loved it that's what matters
absolutely uh the Drew Yari show ooh I'm
gonna have to tune in and check that out
thank you for being with us today big
fan of the show big fan of y'all Anthony
Starr is my doom and Dracula thoughts I
heard rumor he was Dracula four blade
scripts to go
um but I do feel like he'd be a great
villain somewhere in the MCU he does
have like a Cheshire a Cheshire Cat grin
which would be fun for uh for Doom I
don't quite have him as uh sorry as
Dracula I don't quite happen as Doom he
just um there's something about him that
reads uh
American like there's something about
him that like I I have always pictured a
bit of it more like vaguely European
because of that very of Doom I know he's
Romani um so like I that's just how I
see him but he's very captivating and
terrifying so a villain foreshore
absolute vodka I mean it's it's gonna be
fascinating if and when he joins one of
these mains you know like the mainest
stream franchises on the like anything
on the heels of the boys I'm just gonna
be fascinated to see how he then
transitions into something that's a
little bit more genuine about it yeah it
is I'm curious yeah isn't trying to like
directly deconstruct completely the
whole thing
um Jordan Garza appreciates you jumping
back into the Super chats koi I follow
like everything you do but I can't tell
if you're a horror guy or not any hype
for Five Nights at Freddy's movie if not
John I know you are love Matthew Lillard
that's right dude Matthew Lillard is why
I'm excited uh I'm very hyped for Five
Nights at Freddy's it's uh it's a
beloved property my brother and sister
are obsessed with it I'm I'm
invested in it because their love and
because of Matt because of Josh
um I also love what I I've heard about
it Through the Grapevine so no I'm I'm
very much in I think uh the guy that
created it is one of those Minds that
everything he makes is really
interesting to me so um yeah Five Nights
at Freddy's is actually like high on my
radar uh and and like Matt Lillard is a
key part of that and uh and isn't he
isn't Matthew Lillard playing like one
of the he's is he William Afton is he
one of like the main I don't know what's
public
maybe it looks great
is okay that's good I will not lead you
into anything just troubled territory
very excited vaguely either way yeah I
am very excited I'm excited to see how
they differentiated I mean Willie's
Wonderland is the most recent you know
kind of Chuck E cheese-esque horror
movie you also have the Banana Splits
I'm curious to see post those movies how
they you know fully do the five nights
but also you know transcend the idea
that people are going to be pointing
directly at those other movies uh and
you know the five nights precedes as a
game Willie's but all that stuff is the
authority with the boy it's gonna be
interesting to see how the authority
solves the boy's problem yeah exactly
but very excited nevertheless and that
teaser was really sweet and and two just
like the designs of the creatures are
perfect because you can make them real
and they look just like they did in the
game even though the game was not
exactly like a photo real look uh
Christian unpronounceable
challenge accepted and shouts out to you
in Canada appreciate you tuning in uh I
want to see Sophia lillis as Rogue how
do you feel uh she has been my Jean Gray
for a very long time yeah I'm I'm with
that so uh they don't
they often cast blondes as redheads and
it kind of vexes me as a day Walker
Ginger I'd like to see an actual redhead
play a redhead uh so if that's possible
I'd love to see her as Gene Greg I also
like Sevilla list doesn't quite have
that like Southern Belle thing to me
like there's there's a very interesting
uh saved your life yeah there's
something about like the 80s and 90s
like Southern
um I don't know we don't see that
character on screen a lot anymore like I
feel like the the Gina Davis era
um of like Femme Fatale and like you
know that that I want a very actually
Southern
um impossibly attractive because that's
the point of Rogue is like you can't
touch her and she wants to be loved and
touched and appreciated she wants to be
held she wants to be like she feels like
a leper because she can't like touch
anyone and I want to see that character
uh portrayed accurately and I feel like
Sophie Ellis isn't quite that but she is
very much my Jean Gray so I love her as
an X-Men she's not that one for me yeah
I I think we're on the same page as that
although I mean I think she could
certainly handle Rogue and I feel like
she could easily slip into some kind of
accent
um sure but yeah but I would be I would
be excited to see her as Jude
it's like it's burned into my sense
memories I hope they at least yelled
Gene at least once and then we'll all
have in Deadpool three if if uh Hugh
Jackman doesn't if Deadpool 3 doesn't
have you jack been laying in a bed
holding a framed photo okay oh my God
then Ryan has failed us now but do it
right if he doesn't just like pull a
lever and dump a hundred copies of uh of
uh like last what's the last movie that
they really shared together I guess that
would be last stand right dude they
could literally even have a
them go to The Animated Universe in
Deadpool yeah like that X-Men 97 you can
do any of this you could get
spider-verse in there all the stuff we
said about the Multiverse Madness we
were like there's animated frames in
that big multiversal thing you could
actually do in Deadpool
and loot vodka Dakota Jones one virus
effects how's it going bud thank you for
joining us on this live stream today and
uh y'all in the chat keep holding it
down and uh if you if you if you feel
like it you could leave a like on this
video and just do everybody a massive
solid it helps more than you realize
leaving that like it tells YouTube that
uh that that people are engaged they're
actually here they're not just like it's
not in the background we pressed a
button people are getting married today
on the YouTube Dakota Jones says hey
dudes
I hope all is well
it is it is don't worry uh do you think
we need a young Lex to age with Superman
or an established older Lex I'd love to
see an older Lex Esposito Giancarlo uh
like Lex grew up Superman that's like
part of the part of the thing
it'd be weird if like this creepy old
guy was hanging out with a child that's
the version I want bring Kevin Spacey
back it's time he's done enough oh my
God
that's right man Superman we got the
massage parlor wow
I I personally uh I they that's part of
the story is that the Betrayal uh Lex
Luthor feels betrayed that Superman
never revealed himself to him and like
part of how he feels wronged is that
like someone he knew could be deceiving
him and like part of the animosity is
like he not only thinks that it's
dangerous to have Superman but like I've
always gone with the cannon that they
grew up together so like personally I'd
want him the same age
um and and I I love uh Esposito but like
I'm I feel bad for him always having to
play a bad guy because he's just like
he's warm and charming and and like
bubbly and life and like he's a showman
and I feel like people have like kind of
put him into a like Gus spring box like
the guy was in Malcolm X with Denzel
like 20 years before he played jaspering
and I and I feel like no one no one
pregus like acknowledges that incredible
career guys gotta star in the Hollywood
Walk of Fame like I just I want him to
play like I got I want him to act I
don't want him to be trapped that's been
happening lately is I walked somebody
had Amos and Andrew on the old Sam
Jackson Nick Cage movie and he's in that
too it's like everywhere and like you
see young Giancarlo and it's like oh
damn dude you're like Suave and sexy
now but in a in a different way and I
feel like that's still there and could
still be a like that could tap into that
you know yeah but that being said I mean
if they turned around tomorrow and were
like giancarlo's gonna be likes Luther
I'd be like cool let's go he's very
talented I just as as a person I want
him to get to like stretch I feel like
everyone in Breaking Bad at some point
has been pitched as Lex Luthor think
about it it's like you have Brian
Cranston has been pitched as Lex Luthor
you've had Giancarlo Esposito you have
Dean Norris could be a version
Aaron Paul needs to be Lex Luthor how
he's holding like an emerald and he's
like yeah [__] Kryptonite yeah writes
itself kryptonites Mr White and then
Brian is a Jimmy Olsen and they make
Mezcal together perf rights I love it
dos Hombres uh and Dakota clarifies in
the chat uh if soups was like 50 to have
Alexa uh soups is like 30 do I have
Alexa who's like 50. but that was still
some people don't like the childhood
thing I do but it's uh I'm not writing
James Gunn's got all those answers all
right all right uh willy willy T in the
chat Jenna Ortega is too small in
stature for satana in your opinion
I don't know man I never pictured a ton
of needing me because like her her size
comes from her like ability like I've
always seen her as more petite and even
though I mean she is like leading her
own magic shows at points in in her you
know ruse and everything I feel like you
know you come from that culture where
like the assistant is a thing so being
more slight would make some kind of
sense if she had to graduate yeah uh
Gilmer Eric Smith in the chat hoping
Bradley Cooper as Lex Luthor rumor is
true that could be uh honestly that
could be interesting I mean he's so
talented like I can't a hundred percent
visualize it but I think I can I can
imagine it being something that would
surprise me in a very cool and pleasant
way piercing eyeballs um Kiana Chanel
wants Kiki Palmer in whatever role she
wants to play I think that's a good idea
and uh and Cho latte says if Deadpool 3
references that sneaky Wolverine and
Nightcrawler comic cover in any way
they're going to scream I'll show you
after it's not safe for the internet no
good I think yeah well that's a
guarantee that they're gonna reference
that doesn't make them moves like I want
to see how and I bet that's going to be
one of those movies Deadpool 3 where
they push the R so because they know
that they're going to have to rein it in
some so like I'm sure they're gonna push
it way hard so that they can keep a good
amount and cut you know some things they
know are a little too like that's one of
my favorite part of director's
commentaries is when they're like
because when they're like oh yeah we
shot this thing that was way too extreme
and we knew it was never going to make
it in the movie but that's how we got
this other [__] in the movie because we
were like okay we'll cut that then
everyone go see Deadpool 3 in theaters
to show Marvel you want more already
stuff so they can make Deadpool 4 even
more crazy yeah it's really the tester
Millie Alcock as Gwen Stacy Vera Saya
says that would be cool AF uh another 22
Frank back from the patreon we love you
very much and uh Christian
unpronounceable thank you for that new
Super Chat we are going to get to that
ASAP my Gambit says another 22 was Matt
Bomer for a long time I like Grace Van
Dyne for Kitty Pride I really want
Joseph Quinn as Gambit or Cyclops or
something mutant I don't know I mean I
think Joseph Quinn is a good one because
I mean obviously everyone and their mom
including me loves Eddie Munson but he's
at that point right now where it's like
his name gets thrown around but he
hasn't just had the opportunity to play
all the roles so I'm still like excited
for whatever he gets I think going from
stranger things to Marvel is a
trajectory that would make sense for
both parties uh I think it'd be I'd love
to see that but I I Cyclops like Jose
Quinn's not like an Abercrombie goop
like he's the opposite like I've always
Cyclops is you're supposed to be mad
because he's handsome like he's
arrogantly like
Jackson Alan richton's a better Cyclops
for the type
um but like disrespective physical type
but just most excited for for fast X
because he's so fun in that man I just I
just heard he was in it and I was like
oh no way it's like all right awesome
it's a blast too and yeah is Grace Van
Deen related to toy Casper Van Deen says
daughter man that's his daughter yeah
and she is Chrissy wake up so I like
that you lump them together in this and
she is retired though she's retired
Frankie yeah she uh she got harassed
like literally daily for like six months
and was like I'm gonna just not so I
mean hopefully you know she she can if
she wants to come back she can but like
people sucked Christ Church why did she
get what did they harass her for I mean
we're on the internet today she's on the
internet to another scale so like I
can't even imagine what she deals with
so yeah people people are awful and
mental health is more important than
like famous face so yeah people people
ruin that option I'm here for Grace Van
Deen if she wants to come back and be
Kitty Pride I could see that for at
least she's also be a good dazzler look
up dazzler dazzler because I feel like
you need to know and somebody also
pitched uh Rachel zegler as dazzler oh
that's fine look at this this
character's a blast dude oh she'd be
great as Van Dyne okay yeah I'm down for
some dazzle I want a disco right kind of
yeah superhero movie and when I said
Taylor Swift earlier I don't think she's
gonna be a leading role I don't think
dazzler's gonna be like you know
spin-off
no if it's Taylor Swift it will be yeah
there's no you know
Deadpool three here and around the best
friends Taylor Swift as dazzler in
Deadpool 3 make it happen and then it
can be Canon or not like you can bring
into the MCU or not Ryan's watching this
right the stream don't Ryan just jump on
it
Ryan
texting Ryan cast Taylor Swift Deadshot
asks thank you for joining us dead shot
uh Alan richson would be a good MCU
Eddie Brock if Tom Hardy doesn't stay I
would love that so much dude that's
perfect that is that he's literally a
Todd McFarlane drawing yes that's
amazing cosigned oh dude Hells yeah
I'm just so happy for all the Alan
Richardson love overdue
overdue and I'm trying to think like
what else we got him from because uh
because two uh like he's he's
I I don't know he like I know him
obviously I from Reacher now
um but uh I don't know I feel like he's
been around I feel like he's been around
for longer he was uh he was in the
Smallville universe
there you go yeah that's where I knew
him from
ah sorry just adjusting some sizing
things
learning the the the the the the you
know the control Parts the the
coordination of the brain and the
controls usually the guy in the chair
isn't also talking you're doing both
your guy in the chair and running around
dude big respect I mean big respect to
Greg when he is hosting these for you
know having The Octopus arms but also we
went to uh a Double Toasted live show
once um and uh big fans of Double
Toasted here this Channel and you know
watching as Corey Coleman you know live
edited and like curated things for them
to do and it was like playing graphics
and like he's controlling the camera
angles and I'm just like wow man it's
crazy
um so big admiration and appreciate you
guys for putting up with me uh Heather
gear much love to you one of our a
beloved patrons uh super sexy P Jets
over here I wish I could read the
sticker better something something one I
love this little fox guys handsome
little fox Guy painting a little message
and uh does it say you're the one or
something I will be the one you're the
one now Jet Li can we acknowledge that
Andrew Pina is working at Nasa and
watching us what you're way too smart
for this what are you doing Andrew what
do you do yeah I mean don't you know I
don't want any sort of mishaps on our
account no right you know be safe that
space launch correct that's awesome
congratulations that's a cool job that
is the coolest uh okay lunch break at
nasty okay ah that is I am actually
nerding out right now they're of
guardians galaxy fans that's fitting I
like that you're you're cosmically
working and cosmically vibing with MCU
yeah Spidey second yeah I think
Guardians and hey guys like I think a
lot of people will agree that it is
guardians but like what is your favorite
what do you think is the best Trilogy or
or just franchise within the greater
franchise and yeah I would like where
I'm sitting right now I feel like
Guardians is easily the most consistent
because I feel like you know Spider-Man
there's a lot of love that even I have
for pretty much I have for all the
Spider-Man movies to some degree some
more than others but I feel like you
know the average is a little bit more up
and down than you know Guardians is a
crisp three plus a couple auxiliary
things but uh but what a crisp uh
trilogy there and uh yeah I think uh
Captain America is the one that comes
the next closest yeah I agree and then
maybe Iron Man after that I'm an Iron
Man 3 Defender but two certainly
happened
I don't hate I like Iron Man 2 it's like
I watch bad and it's not Guardians I
just get and acknowledge the problems
but at the same time I'm like I don't
know I like Mickey Rourke and his bird
and I like Sam Rockwell as uh as uh uh
Justin Hammer yeah the other because he
actually went out for Tony yeah then
they were like we gotta almost Tony oh
Justin hammer it was perfect I mean
honestly though like Guardians I put in
contention for all the time great
trilogies not comic book trilogies it's
it's just movies yeah Hondo p uh hey uh
yeah uh G Colby peas there's a koi we
get into so many debates with Corey
Martin I would love to see you on a
Double Toasted oh is that those guys
yeah the two main like they have a lot
of uh different contributors and
collaborators but Corey is the main guy
in them what's their handling the Hat uh
Double Toasted are they like pop culture
yeah yeah yeah they do uh a lot of I
first discovered them in a previous
iteration where they were doing movie
reviews in animated forms their
animators as well but yeah right now
they do basically like long-form talk
shows that then get broken up into movie
reviews and you know just riffing on
yeah pop culture and things like that
and uh they have been holding it down
for a long time out of Austin Texas
starting on they had like a cable access
show and then they had like web stuff
and now they're you know in their
current iterations oh it's still toasted
so uh yeah big respect for them and uh
loved Alan Richman Alan Richardson since
Aquaman and Smallville Gracie and Ryan
says and especially Blue Mountain State
I have not seen Blue Mountain State but
I can imagine I I know some people who
love that show yes played Hawk and uh he
was a Rob lifeld character but Hawk yeah
the Titans right there Hawk on Titans
there you go dude I'm glad that he has
like a big old base of stuff uh that I
didn't even realize yeah
um and Tristan Clark uh yes I I think we
if we haven't gotten to you than it is
in the Tandem and we're going to keep
going here on the super chats and we're
gonna check back in on the stream Labs
so if you haven't heard your name yet or
your question or your input whatever it
might be hold tight and if we get to the
end and it's still not there then we can
figure that out
um and yeah and uh Garth McMurray what's
up hey man uh yeah that was one of the
coolest ever moments was uh yeah we got
to Greg and I uh did a teams match
against them oh that's awesome
schmowdown and uh and yeah like I
initially I wasn't even supposed to be a
part of that and I was ever like
immensely grateful to have been included
when when Greg was like can we do it as
a team could John that's awesome like I
I I am endlessly super grateful uh that
that happened because that was like one
of the biggest nerd mode like they were
in the in our space they're probably the
channel I have watched the longest
because in high school
spill.com was uh huge for me that's
awesome I've only heard good things
about it I just know their names I've
only heard like double toast is great I
didn't know they had like I don't know
yeah and I mean it's fun I I think it's
fun to go back into the archive and look
up like they would do podcast form so
you could hear the long form review and
then you could go and look at like the
six minute cut down where it's like the
animated character versions of everybody
that's rad I like that yeah and uh and
yeah Jonathan Majors is definitely got
to be happy that uh strike is going on
Greg's just in here just don't worry
Jonathan's gonna be fine we'll see how
this goes uh Jordan Garza beans uh been
seeing oh here's here's something that
we touched on earlier but I saw your
comment and so we held off on getting
too deep until we got here but Jordan
Garza says I've been seeing loveness
Jeff loveness isn't with the MCU anymore
thoughts uh Jeff lovnes was uh one of
the writers for uh Kang Dynasty
and uh was he on quantumania as well uh
uh at least you know one of the current
wave of Marvel writers uh brought over
from most notably Rick and Morty a big
sentiment I feel like among less than
satisfied MCU fans lately has been uh no
more of these Rick and Morty writers uh
which I am very curious about and I get
why you know you have Michael you're
Michael Waldron you have Jeff loveness
and probably some other names that I'm
you know forgetting now who have yeah
been brought over from the Rick and
Morty side of things and it does uh it
does make me wonder I mean the
the quantumania to me is one of those
movies where
like yeah I have issues with the script
but with these films I always feel kind
of odd from a fan perspective because I
don't know where to place the credit or
the blame on certain things because
yeah like where is the script in this
process and whose input is really the
script that you see at the end of the
day so while some people are rejoicing
about this I don't know exactly how to
feel uh I mean like I said I didn't love
quantumania and I thought it left a lot
of opportunities on the table for
interesting character work and
storytelling
um not that it didn't have fun charms
that I also enjoyed but at the same time
yeah I just don't know really I see
people rejoicing about stuff like this
and I don't know how much to join that
I'm never happy for anyone losing a job
but I'm always happy when things improve
by them like looking at a thing and
going like okay we can fix it so like
I'm not happy last job we got paid I
hope everything worked out for him I
don't know the guy but uh I never
understood the Rick and Morty thing like
that's not my thing so like I know
people love Rick and Morty but um I
don't find it funny so like I'm hoping
that whoever comes in neck is more
selfishly I want it to be more my cup of
tea so I don't have anything against
that guy science just like comedy
subjective so not my Tempo yeah I would
have to agree with that I mean I don't
know it was one of those things where I
would have been happy to kind of look
and see what else you can deliver us
because too I mean like I really liked a
lot of Michael Waldron's the writing and
Loki's genius yeah like I liked the way
that that was written largely anyway and
again I'm sure the committee is involved
with that but then you know uh
Multiverse of Madness a bit more of a
rough experience then again apparently I
I just read something recently that said
it was Waldron's idea to do the whole
Illuminati thing which was kind of a
surprise to me so I'm like oh well that
suggests maybe a bit more direct input
taken from the writer than I might
expect because I guess I I kind of
expected these movies in particular like
they always say like if you want to
really be in the writer's medium go to
TV yeah whereas movies I feel like yeah
you got the producer the director of
various other people who can easily
usurp the writer on the totem pole but
then again I hear something like that
such a distinct and controversial part
of that movie being the you know the
writers call interesting but yeah I'm
kind of with you I'm not really happy
that Jeff loveness has lost this job if
it that is in fact the case
um I just yeah it's like I'll never
celebrate someone losing a job I will
you know be happy to watch
whoever the creatives are try and find
the right pick for the job yeah I want
the right person to write the movie so
however that looks and uh you know all
the best whatever he does next I put
some dope also uh just a just a warning
we're gonna close up the super chats in
a few minutes uh we do got a fair amount
to get back through but uh you know we
should we should start winding down
sooner than later so just uh just a
heads up but we still got time we're
going we gotta bring him up we're gonna
hit them all but uh but yeah if you got
any last minute thoughts just start to
kind of formulating what those could be
and uh yeah just want to make sure uh
nobody gets missed or anything like that
Deadshot is back Floyd how you doing
buddy uh if Hardy stays in secret Wars
Tom's Peter promises to save the world
but in the end his world gets destroyed
with all his friends dead and he is in
the MCU now with the hatred towards
Spider-Man not a bad pitch Coy what do
you think is that an all right pitch I
think uh it'll be very interesting to
see what level of vigilance good bad
they do with Spider-Man I like this idea
because it does tie animosity into that
I do think they need to in some way
instill the white uh Spider at some
point be really cool to end the movie
with like that and that being like a
fully formed Venom like you get all the
way there I honestly think um there
needs to be another Venom in the MCU
separate like I I think the Tom Hardy
Venom is Chen yeah I mean obviously
she's got to get chenum it's gonna be uh
Michelle Williams a little tiny Venom
um but I I do think that you know
wrapping it out with a Venom to
Spider-Man fight would be great I just
don't know if if Tom Hardy wants to play
this role forever so as long as he wants
to I'm down I think he's ready forever
love it never stop never stopping but I
love that pitch sell it absolutely and
yeah like
God that is the thing is like when are
they gonna make him fight Spider-Man
like I I you know as a child was always
like Venom's got his own Comics is
pretty sweet he gets to be his own dude
but also where's Spider-Man come on yeah
we had two out of three movies at the
time it's the movies you gotta do it you
know like I can't imagine three would
not have Spider-Man yeah absolute vodka
uh especially with now an R-rated Craven
movie that gives me a lot of Hope for an
R-rated Venom movie and that gives me a
lot of Hope for the Sony Universe going
forward because already Craven that
that's gonna be a blast yeah absolutely
uh moving ahead and yes we're gonna
close the super chats in about 20 20-ish
minutes so uh you know like I said if
you got any last minute straggling
thoughts or anything you want to hear
especially the expert opinion on throw
those out there and we will make sure to
get to them so yeah just just a 20 min
this is your 20 minute warning one you
know we'll give you a couple more
warnings just in case but yeah by about
150 we will close the super chats and
start wrapping the stream down so uh so
yeah just want to make sure y'all are
aware nerd Calvin V nerd cat not just
any nerd named Calvin but it's the nerd
Calvin I want Star-Lord to lead he has
matured a lot
um I mean certainly
I could I don't know like I I I can see
him in a different leadership position I
don't know what that would be it's like
I like where they left the Guardians in
Rocket's hands and I like that they let
Peter go home and you know get back in
touch with human life
so I don't really know what he would
lead but I like the arc into maturity
and what that suggests for his ability
as a leader moving forward so that is
you know something I could get on board
with you uh yeah for great logo by the
way uh I I think uh Star-Lord is
um I love that he like whooped you know
Iron Man and Spider-Man in that brief
moment like you saw his capabilities of
fighter game really seen him in those
environments a lot so there's definitely
potential there but I also
um as a character I do want him to kind
of have his Walkabout era so like I
don't know if I'd wanted to jump into
another team you know what I mean like
I'd be kind of nice to see him get to
like whatever that looks like I feel
like it's Unique to not have him on a
team so much like Spider-Man like I just
let let Spider-Man not be an Avenger for
a while I'd love to see Star-Lord get to
like figure out Earth life sure yeah I
just want a slice of Life yeah Disney
Plus show of Chris Pratt just
discovering ice cream absolutely put it
with the Jeff Goldblum show Jeff
Goldblum like just like discovering
things but make it the Grand Master and
starlord absolutely I like that quite a
bit uh oh and hey Bucky Barnes thank you
for holding it down in the chat and uh
Christian unpronounceable as well
appreciate you all helping us out uh
with uh yeah just just keeping things
moving smoothly and uh philosophy don't
worry you are super enough as you are
super chats or no again you're super got
a little under 20 minutes before we
close those out so throw in your
thoughts while you can uh and hey Alma
pal what do you got for us a lot has
been adapted from Hickman Comics do you
think Marvel will adapt his F4 his
Fantastic Four run and House of powers
of and house and powers of X House of X
and powers of X into the MCU especially
because House of X and powers of X is a
reboot origin for X-Men
I know people love the Croco stuff but
the whole thing about X-Men is that they
live in a world that hates and fears
them Croco just takes away all the
stakes you're just like they're Immortal
they're out on an island just like
boning like burning man and like they're
having a good time
isn't working for you about this it's a
great what if it's a great else world
it's a great alternative story but it's
not the story like I'm a little burnt
out of hawks pox I'm it's been going for
too long
um it's like five years in and like it's
a cool concept but like it doesn't feel
like the X-Men the X-Men are dealing
with heady themes and like lots of very
big philosophical quandaries and they're
looking at the world but they're still
fun and I just don't find hawksbox that
fun they literally cut to parties and
Galas to get back to fun and then they
go back to like there's literally a a
council where they all sit around and
debate politics and I was like I get it
it's just it's it's not the balance of
fun and uh Intrigue is shifted to more
like debate and like it just doesn't
feel like X-Men to me um so personally
I'm not as big in the Hickman stuff as
everyone else is I'm happy people are
happy with the X-Men I'm glad it's
selling it's the best X-Men is sold in a
long time it's not my X-Men and that's
okay because like not everything's gonna
be like I love runs that other people
don't personally I hope they don't uh
and I definitely feel like uh Hickman is
a genius writer but I actually like him
more when he's not writing um superhero
stuff I like Hickman's Indies better uh
so like I got nothing against the
writing and I got nothing against those
stories it just doesn't feel like a
cinematic take in the X-Men I want the
90s X-Men I want the Jim Lee era you
know Illustrated stuff I want it to feel
we've never gotten X-Men we've gotten
Brian Singer mutant movies it's time to
actually get X-Men and like you cannot
make another else world I need X-Men
absolutely I feel you uh respectfully so
uh you know just given some of the
comments here how would you say uh
what's your stance on fun koi you know I
like fun
um as much as I love a good Burning Man
tryst it's only for a week for a reason
because it's not sustainable sure sure I
I I enjoy a little fun in some of these
but it's weird you know because I feel
like with Multiverse Madness they almost
open up the door for a potential kind of
House of well well he had House of M
with uh oh yeah House of M is definitely
but that's another else world like it's
just you have so many options and like I
just feel like you need the foundation
first and the foundation is these are
our Outsiders like the whole metaphor of
X-Men is they represent the oppressed
people so if you introduce the oppressed
people whatever uh oppression you
identify with by having their own island
off from Humanity that doesn't allow you
to tell the stories that I think people
need like people need to feel seen
people need to identify with these
characters and if they're a mortal
foreign
[Music]
what happened to the MCU Spider-Man
animated series I don't know I mean I
feel like I had updates in a while yeah
I feel like everything has just kind of
been spaced out right now I wouldn't be
surprised if there is like a
we'll I'm still waiting for the idea of
like cancellations of planned things but
I feel like they are they're just maybe
I thought that one got canceled and then
like I didn't really yeah it might be I
think I heard something about them
reworking it but uh but yeah I mean I
feel like you know at some point it will
come to fruition I think now there's at
a point where they're taking their time
a little bit more yeah uh Eagles Span in
the uh chat also says dark hole Diaries
is gonna highly debut Ghost Writer I
don't know could be cool Tim will tell
but uh I I feel yeah definitely
potential for that although it would be
nice to just let them you know that just
be be their thing
without I don't know it's weird like
it's fun to be like bring me a bunch of
other characters into this thing that's
about these characters but also I
sometimes just want to focus on also
yeah that's why people people didn't
like phase four because it was like all
these new things now people are like
give me more new things I'm like maybe
we fix the things we have yeah yeah yeah
but you know hey who who wants what they
got when there's more to get koi
too real yeah
um do you think we can still have a
Guardians of the Galaxy 4 with the new
team I hope they I don't know like I I
hope they do it I would be kind of
bummed if we went back to either leave
Guardians just indefinitely Or uh yeah
bring that team back and give it a try
and get a very specific director like I
don't care what type of director I want
the best like James Gunn brought a
specificity that's what made it work
yeah keep it unique keep it like
different from the rest of the MCU like
his Guardians was give it to Edgar
Wright as an apology for Ant-Man oh that
would be fun
fun fun fun koi got needle drops you got
a very uh bombastic style of directing
he's good with teams I think he'd be a
great uh any news on what if season two
haven't heard much about that yet either
I feel like they're I think they're
holding that until they see how long the
writers strike is
I think a lot of things and that's the
thing too is with the writer strike and
now the threat of more uh uh unions
joining the strike I mean yeah sag May
and then people were speculating the
directors will also the DGA will go on
strike yeah I think that's why iron
Hearts next year I think they're just
like we need this because we can't make
stuff it's funny yeah it's like we're at
that point right now where there's still
stuff but uh and there's still stings in
the pipe but you know if this strike
goes on long enough which I mean most
strikes of this variety only last months
yeah sometimes many months but uh and
I'm curious if we'll get to that point
where it starts to affect like we're
kind of running out of like fresh
content guys like what do we do yeah and
I feel like there's a chance that this
could become something a bit
unprecedented in terms of yeah like just
the effect the the ripple effect that
this will have and how much this will
affect uh just got our momentum back
like it just uh but I mean pay people
what they owe uh director of Dungeons
and Dragons from new Guardians love that
maximoff anomaly I'm a big fan of
Jonathan Goldstein John Francis daily oh
that's right yeah and I mean I I it
always blows my mind that uh yeah John
Francis Daley at least like I know him
from as many people probably do from
like Freaks and Geeks and things like
that so uh like the fact that they've
carved such a a path as a freaking geeky
path a freaky geeky path also worked on
Spider-Man homecoming oh we got some
some uh some stream Labs oh yes right
what do they do on Spiderman home they
wrote in that's right a big chunk they
were like the head writers heck yeah
they're in there dude JF dude and uh
Goldstein Goldstein gold state and John
France data John's couple of johns with
John and John
it's my new show
uh let's go over to these stream labs
and thank you so much as well uh again
all contributions are are very much
appreciated you don't you know none of
you have to do any of it we're hitting
the chat too we're in here and uh we do
very much appreciate you uh you still
got a few minutes if you want to get in
a super chat or a stream Lab about 10
minutes so uh we're gonna close up super
chats and all that stuff in about 10. so
just yeah if you've got anything else
you want to hear and make sure gets
addressed that's the place to do it uh
triscuitclark9522 love that name like
Triscuits I'm a big Triscuit fan slept
on food Triscuits uh got a great texture
they really do mouth feel very unique
satisfying not too crunchy but like a
night it's like a soft crunch it doesn't
hurt like a kettle chip sometimes kettle
chips too hard sure yeah yeah I'm with
you leave your uh your most mouth
friendly chip in the comments yeah let
us know what's your mouth feel feel I
don't know if this will be seen But
thank you koi oh it'll be seen don't
worry all of them we gotta honor you so
uh so rest assured we're we're we in the
immortal words of all of the people in
Avatar I see you
oh and that's the hand thing is there a
handling enough that's oh yeah that's
Chris Pratt oh he's blocking the
dinosaurs yeah okay it's also morbius
touching the glass of the bats but thank
you koi for being you and for explaining
my comic collection uh what expanding my
comment collection what characters would
you guys like to see in the new DCU that
have only been seen in only a little bit
of animated shows or cameos like
metamorpho or metal man
Mr Miracle Mr miracle I love him I need
him I miss him I want him uh uh Plastic
Man Plastic Man
um who else uh I'd love to see Kyle
Rainer it'll never happen but I can
Vector give me special oh Specter be
great I want Specter I think Donna Troy
is interesting if you write her Rel uh
what write her well uh
uh I think that girl has never gotten
her do I think Barbara Gordon's a
fantastic and fascinating character uh I
think Nightwing is is inevitable but man
I want it
um oh I hope they do well by Nightwing
yeah those those are the one like we're
getting a swamp thing like they're yeah
those those are the ones that jump out
absolutely it's a good good smattering
of picks and uh and I'll always throw in
a vote for my my man Grundy I mean come
on I feel like there's nothing you can
really do in a very big way but he can
open it feels like he's like whenever he
shows up in any of like the the live
action Media or the the animated Media
or whatever it is he's always just kind
of like one of many in a fight
but you'll get so excited for that fight
I bill
olenti did you guys watch the secret
Invasion short I think secret invasion
is my most anticipated show for 2023
although Loki is my favorite MCU show so
far I've enjoyed them all to some degree
which are you more excited for including
Echo secret Invasion short Is this
different from uh from the the promos
we've seen uh thus far yeah no about a
short is there what
you're breaking news to us yeah I guess
uh yeah send it if I haven't seen it and
send it uh because yeah we've seen the
trailers and I'm certainly excited for
secret Invasion I mean I guess in this
hierarchy I'm most excited for Loki just
because Loki you know keeps on grappling
with one division at the top of uh the
uh you know shows for me in terms of
just uh you know quality and love and
all that other enthusiasm and stuff
um but I mean I'm really rooting for
Echo just because I I just I I want that
to be good like I just I don't want it
to be this thing where they're trying to
dump it because it sucks and I feel like
that would be such a bummer especially
for that actress who like did a great
job in Hawkeye and you know I think kind
of had that that show kind of bungled I
think a lot of what they gave their
talent and so I feel like people might
be getting a raw deal with Echo and I
just hope that I'm I'm rooting the most
for that one secret Invasion will be fun
but because I'm excited to see them go
back to something more grounded in
Espionage based you know uh secret
Innovation is seemingly the spiritual
sequel to my like second favorite Marvel
thing ever which is Winter Soldiers so
I'm a little bit more a little bit more
low-key only because it surprised me
like Loki came out of nowhere and I
expected like
I don't know good but it was exceptional
and then also uh two of my buddies
directed Loki season dude so I'm like I
can't really like separate that like I'm
really excited for my guys to like
Thrive so Loki season two for
professional and personal reasons uh
also I want to see uh Owen Wilson get
his jet ski that oh there's got to be
like a whole jet ski Universe the whole
app just a hole they gotta they gotta
solve quantum theory on jet ski
that's what I want someone out there is
already there's some some like Quantum
physicist out there is like living their
best life being like I'm real life
mobile well there's like a wavelength
Mobius there's like wavelength theories
right so you tie the waves of like the
wavelengths for time through jet ski and
then you have to solve like the
algorithm of what waves are as it
relates to time because the moon cycles
around a certain amount of time causing
waves so jet skis are a logical place to
discuss how time relates to space Also
Mr terrific we we didn't throw out Mr
terrific he's my Sterling Cape Brown
pick man yeah yeah oh yeah Mr Rick is
definitely put them in yeah put him in
the live action put them in the put them
in coach also human target would be cool
that's that comic I was telling you
about that the Greg Smallwood art I love
yeah oh dang that's right I gotta pick
that up still yeah five minutes in case
just five minute warning for the super
chats if anybody else wants to throw in
a question comment or concern and let's
move on to the next stream Lab over here
if Jonathan Majors thank you olenti by
the way for contributing this uh if
Jonathan Majors doesn't continue his
Kang I hope they don't grab the dynasty
storyline because I'm super intrigued by
it I would love John David Washington in
the role if they have to recast don't
swap Kang out for high evolutionary uh
hey I mean John David Washington I think
would be an interesting choice too I I
think I I would be thrilled I know he's
got you know acting chops and intensity
and you know presence and I haven't yet
seen him you know be that big
Shakespearean like you know I am okay
you know I get like that big
over-the-top you know Gusto and I think
that would be a cool element to unlock
you know in his performing so uh I would
be certainly interested in that casting
what do you think I don't know if this
is a
controversial thing to say make him a
white guy no actually it's similar stuff
but the other way I would I would love
to see if they're gonna recast to not
have someone similar to to Jonathan
Majors you know I mean like if they're
because I feel like the high Evolution
when I think about it everyone keeps
saying evolutionary I'm like yeah but
that just feels like they had to so it
doesn't feel natural I want High
evolutionary to stay so I also feel like
if you recast an African-American guy
with another American guy it'll feel
like that's gonna be them putting
themselves in a position of like
comparison yeah but if you cast like a
woman as Kang they're not gonna compare
they're not gonna go like her
performance wasn't Jonathan Majors where
he is King but like something that's
more
over here so you don't go like let me
look at how they played it right because
you can't do anything so what if the
Conqueror is a woman like what if they
because like there's not a lot of female
villains in Marvel and like there's also
if they keep evolutionary around as his
own villain I think that he'll get more
of a time to shine if he's not being
compared yeah so like I don't know like
a female okay sure I'm with it actually
that's a that's not a bad call and I
think it's yeah do something that won't
happen distance from just comparing the
entire because that's not fair to like
yeah down David Washington uh John
boyega any of the actors I keep hearing
tossed around that's not fair to them to
like if someone likes the performance
Majors better so get someone totally
different Christian unpronounceable in
the chat says there was a great human
target TV show a few years ago so I
don't know I was based in the comic I
just remember seeing that that's
interesting go go look at that hell yeah
an Eagles fan you're saying they scrap
Majors you're saying they rewrote the
ending of Loki season two is any of this
verified or are you just running me up
uh a yarn here if it's verified let us
know ill Tortuga a mystical quest to the
Isle of Tortuga what do you guys think
thank you for contributing to the chat
uh what do you guys think about the
mcu's first F-bomb being dropped in
Guardians 3 was it memorable I
personally think the first F-bomb should
have gone into Fury but I still thought
press delivery was great
um I feel like that I think they did it
the right way because it has to be to me
the first F-bomb in the MCU it was nice
that they did it as like part of
something that could almost be throwaway
like I feel like if Sam Jackson did it
it would have to be like push in right
as he you know loads the the MF into the
chamber you know
not that I would ever uh poo poo a a Sam
Jackson you know F-bomb because please
secret Invasion that's kind of all I
want but uh but yeah I'm happy with the
way I'm happy with it I thought it was
funny I thought it was a great I like
that it wasn't like oh my God but I also
I think that's that's more natural and
funny but uh I that delivery has stuck
with me and each time I've seen the
movie it's made me laugh I also like the
original idea for the iPhone was going
to be Tony Stark sure like that would
have been Genius Like You Remember like
did you hear about that yeah
Thanos so basically like instead of uh I
am Iron Man like the lady just like you
like you literally like oh so like I
think that would have been great but
like because it literally about the end
of phase three is just an F-bomb would
have been funny but I did like this one
as well sure sure Sammy boy thank you
for contributing into the chat a couple
more minutes left people if you want to
get a Super Chat endless their last
warning basically in a minute in in 60
seconds I'm gonna close the Super Chat
so if anybody else has something get it
in now uh Sammy boy I have a theory with
the concept of counter Earth I think
that's a way to have the celestial birth
on Earth still have uh
and still have humankind you think a my
hero Academia could work in live action
I think with the superhero boom lowering
and Anime going up it's a win
um so okay counter Earth
um
have a that's a way to have a Celestial
burst on Earth and still have humankind
I mean
you mean like counter Earth where the
the destroyed counter Earth though yeah
it's completely
yeah I don't know I don't know how these
correlate personally and I mean like I
even kind of understanding what you're
saying it's like if the celestial came
out of the counter Earth that would
still destroy the counter Earth and the
Human animals thereon so I think uh the
Earth that the eternals are on is not
the Earth of ours and I think that we're
gonna find out I my big theory is that
Tang brings a lot of Earth together and
then we realize that these are all
different Earths and then the Collision
is Secret Wars I think I think phase
four we've already met different Earths
so I think that when they come together
that's your oars so I think the reason
we haven't seen the celestial hand in
another movie is because it's not our
Earth so I I'm curious what that does
and I think my hero Academia is
exceptional I'm about to start season
five on my channel I review it like
every four or five episodes I have not
started uh but I love the first four
seasons and I would just worry with live
action because of how well they do the
X-Men right on my hero Academia but that
means they invest time in so many
characters I don't know if live action
could do it justice but I'd be there
opening night yeah
someday like anime is the next one in
the video game tandem where it's like
someone's gonna nail the live-action
version but yeah I feel like my hero
would just beg so
like it's one of the other and it's like
ah but uh I'd be I'd be here for it if I
think it's possible and and with the
superhero boom being what it is it
certainly could work I just think yeah
there are obstacles uh that would need
to be kind of mounted
um Michael Mack y'all ever see a show
called Timeless Goran visnik as Doom is
one of mine not a huge name but a very
underrated actor koi currently loving
world tree Daredevil Punisher
Fantastic Four Miles Morales Ivy and
Batman current favorite Comics Big Love
from Scotland as always go keep it keep
it you know a little bit contained
because we we gotta all of those are
incredible polls by the way everything
he just said are in my top comics so I'm
just gonna read my last three weeks very
quickly my favorite comments from last
three weeks have been uh Adventures of
Superman John Kent Batman 135 Carnage
rain surprise the hell to me hauntology
was really good hey kids comics volume 3
Moon Knight Peacemaker tries hard as
just like James Gunner a peacemaker so
it's really fun poison ivy actually made
my cut I loved it as well Scarlet Witch
the new series actually introduces Darcy
from the movies into the comic books her
first comic candidates in The Scarlet
witch series and it feels episodic and
delightful Shazam just rebooted the
number one that I really dug Spider-Man
number eight brings in the spider-verse
it's I think kind of tie into these
spider-verse movies and then from the
end of last month I loved Action Comics
ambassadors is a really good new indie
it's written by Mark Miller and it kind
of feels like if the X-Men took place
today but someone had control over
mutations and how would different
governments regulate that power if
someone had a billion dollar industry
where they could make Heroes and other
companies are vying for that power it's
a really interesting take on uh both
mutants and capitalism Daredevil is also
on my list the new Deadpool's a lot more
fun than I expected deep Cuts is really
solid Doctor Strange just rebooted with
issue too I'm really enjoying it Green
Arrow is also brand new indigo children
is another Indie that I'm digging as
well as the one you mentioned their
world tree just dropped and I really dug
it final few is going to be Invincible
Iron Man which Gary Duggan is crushing
on local man interesting commentary on
what if you're a like Great Lakes
Avenger level hero and you mess up and
then you go back to your town and
everyone hates you because you did
something wrong but you were a hero now
you're scorned neighbors is also really
fascinating Indie Riddler year one is
written by Paul Dano it's basically his
head Canon origin of the Riddler and it
takes place in the Robert Pattinson
Universe you find out Riddler's origin
and Pattinson's Batman's in there which
is a fascinating way to tell that story
Thor number 33 torrent number three and
then wool tree number one made my cut as
well that's just the last two weeks of
comics my favorites and I really like
your taste Boogie that was that was a
you said quick that was beautiful Koi
said quick I read 70 Comics a week those
are my top 10 for each week and Nobody
Does it quick quite like you you should
do the fine print for radio apps Micro
Machines I'm ready just call
fluff ball thank you so much and uh and
yes this is the last call closing down
the super chats uh so if you can get it
in before I hit the button then you got
it
um guys fluffball says and thank you
fluffball for contributing to the stream
Labs over here really love how
kind-hearted and wholesome you are
screw you buddy yeah who do you think
you are being nice to us being nice to
you yeah a subversive joke accomplished
thank you though we do uh you know we we
try to bring that good nature and I
appreciate that you appreciate it
because guess what we're talking about
comics and movies
victory yeah like come on privilege uh
and also love that you talk openly about
going to therapy I wish more men would
talk about it thank you for always
making my days better best from rainy
Switzerland oh we've been we've been
having some of that rainy weather too
and uh yeah absolutely man therapy is
good for you you it it it's uh I think
everybody and not everybody does have
access to this but everybody should have
access to somebody who can kind of help
you figure out the circumstances of your
life but who has no direct investment in
the outcome and uh and yeah like
everybody's got something that's
difficult to process and difficult to
talk through and uh and having a space
to do that is vitally important because
it's very easy to have that stuff just
Bubble Up and and you know ferment in
your head so not only is Ted lasso I
think the best comedy on TV right now
but I also think it's the most important
show because it's a sports show that
isn't about sports it's about being a
man that deals with emotions and the
female characters are actually written
as well like this is a show that
balances so many nuanced things and also
subverts expectations because it's able
to go like hey you think the plot line
is going this way oh it's actually over
here and then at the end of every
episode you get morals and it deals with
mental health and I think that uh that's
one just my commercial for Ted lasso but
I also love that it's a loud therapy to
be in the conversation a lot more
because something that mainstream
addressing it it's so weird that it
wasn't but I I don't think I'd be here
without therapy like I don't I would not
survive working on the internet I would
not survive dealing with fans of comics
and movies on the internet without
therapy and I also don't think La would
be digestible because this is a really
hard town and I think that like we've
all lived through so much crap as a
macro the micro of what we do for living
plus the macro of the pandemic and and
civil rights movements and so many
things we're going through and now like
the Market's collapsing so money's worth
it's it's a lot so therapy is the most
important thing I think any of us can do
and there's literally nothing wrong with
it there's not a single negative like if
you have any means to do it it can only
help worst case scenario you spend an
hour and you get to talk about stuff
that you wish you'd thought of before
and best case scenario it can literally
change your life could not recommend it
more absolute vodka super chats have
been closed my friends but uh you can
still get a super sticker in there if
you are so inclined and we will read off
your name and we will be delighted by
the stick Garth Harkness McMurray thank
you for joining us and for contributing
thank you for holding it down everybody
every time somebody comes in here and
sees your name they're like oh Garth
slight correction in March 2023 Grace
Van Deen stated during a twitch live
stream that she would be focusing more
of her time on streaming over acting
after being sexually propositioned by a
producer during oh that's a movie way
worse Jesus it wasn't internet comments
yeah that's that's wretched I'm I'm
sorry I was wrong and I'm more sorry
that's the reason Jesus that is awful
Yeah Boy oof I hope she's happy doing
what she's doing heart goes out to her
like
that's awful I didn't even casting is
not your Casting Couch yeah people
shills uh think and and Garth thank you
for clarifying that because uh yeah that
is a significant element to that story
um shills as we all are hey koi uh what
do you think and thank you for
contributing by the way uh Hey koi what
do you think about Marvel Comics killing
off Kamala Khan in the comics I don't
think it's a good idea and they're just
using it to make her mutant in the
comics
um I do think that's part of why they're
doing it is it's gonna bring her you
know they can they can born her again
and make it let her not an inhuman been
mutant but I also think that um I don't
know if a character that hasn't died
like I was trying to think of an example
like there used to be a rule in comics
where uh only it was it was only Uncle
Ben uh Bucky and Gwen Stacy stayed dead
that was the rule that was literally the
and like you may notice uh Uncle Ben's
dead but like it's people die um so I
think it is definitely a uh marketing
gimmick and I don't love it but I also
think that you know it's having us talk
about Comics so that's needed like I
don't love that that's what it takes I
don't love that it takes a character
dying to come back for a major news
publication to talk about it but you
also need to sell these Comics so
whenever it happens if I was like all
right I guess sales were low that
quarter and Like Comics are selling
better than they have in a long time now
that they're back but it still has to
continue on so don't love it but juice
worth squeeze for sales
and and it's funny I saw somebody post
like a meme of like you know when they
announce a comic character is being
killed off and it's just James James
Franco in the news from uh first time
first time yeah I couldn't help but but
thicker at that and I mean too very very
quickly is that a thing Comics do like
do Comics hype up like we're gonna kill
this character so tune in like I feel
like that would in a movie would be like
don't tell me that this wasn't a
Spider-Man comic and they basically went
like the most shocking independition
they didn't say who it was and then when
it got out everybody started talking
about it so again marketing like it's
literally just so we talk about it sure
but sometimes they do do that sometimes
they're like in five issues Booster Gold
dies and then you go like how and like
so yeah there's two sides to the death
coin and uh jahir Adrian Gutierrez Perez
uh I hope I said your name correctly uh
I shouts out to your little brother
Fabian Fabian I hope you're doing well
yay you're a good dude all right and I
hope uh you your brother is good to you
as well and if he's not you let us know
and uh and uh I don't know we'll go you
know comment toward him or something
like that but you seem like a good
brother for uh yeah
and uh and Bucky Barnes I'm glad the VA
is is like you know equipped to support
you I know that there's a lot of trouble
Across the Nation just with especially
like veteran care and and uh mental
health uh you know care for veterans and
stuff like that so I'm glad that you
have access to that that really uh it is
heartening to hear hell yeah and uh and
people love you spitting yeah it's Gotta
drop them fruits all right let's hop
into our last uh little Super Chat uh uh
array right here just gonna refresh the
page a really quickly
um but yeah look over the chat is
anybody uh let's see let's see let's see
Bucky we talked to Chino Hills Marvel's
trying to treat Miss Marvel's death like
is that Superman is up her character
with barely in history disagree actually
I think she's more consistent Superman's
ever been in her five-year run she's
done a lot more until a lot more
consistent stories I think Japan's a
bigger character but I don't think he's
as consistent as his Marvel so yes
bigger character sure but as impactful
uh I mean sorry two Brands obviously
more impactful but the death might be
impactful because of how consistent Miss
Marvel is uh did I watch Sandman I've
not yet because I want to actually watch
it and I haven't had time to like sit
and commit like the hours of focus I
want to watch watch it when it's on uh
good omen season two Christian's very
excited about
um there's one more streamlabs in there
according to Garth um okay we got you
yep we're in the final stretch we're in
the end game now yes we're in the end
game now all right those those live
chats I could see I got the I got the
five that were on screen you so money
baby you're so freaking money koi your
your Miss money Penny that's crazy that
the guy that came up with that phrase is
now like running all of like Star Wars I
know like that that expression and now
he's like he started Marvel and like now
he's like got money I just respect that
he doesn't get the credit Garza's Garth
no he doesn't really give favro your
money flowers the human target had an
80s TV series starring Rick Springfield
and then the 2010 TV series starring
Mark Valley and Jackie Earl Haley he
also appeared in the arrowverse TV shows
Barefoot that's awesome uh I loved that
there was an 80s show about this guy I
knew the 2010's one was on because it
was advertised at Comic-Con ironically I
didn't realize it was a comp like the
comic uh that's fantastic he's such a
weird fun character I love that hell's
yeah olenti back in these stream Labs
thank you so much you're our last stream
Lab as of now I think if only uh if if
the only reason for a recast is because
of an off-screen issue they should stick
with an actor of the same race or gender
otherwise it's changing the planned
story because of the off-screen issue
interesting idea though I get where
you're coming from although at this same
time I feel like built into this
character is the ability is just the
idea that
I I mean
I'm of two minds about this in on the
one hand we've established that variants
don't always look the same and they
don't always have the same face they're
not always the same gender Etc uh
however you know like the Council of
Kings seems to be mostly people who look
like Jonathan Majors or aliens you know
so I I I can see that too basically and
it's a very difficult issue to find the
right answer toward and I'm part of me
goes can you find a middle ground even
yeah I I have no I there's a reason I'm
not in casting yeah absolutely you're
not uh Sarah Holly Finn man she is such
a champion Johnny thank you so much for
chiming in in the super chats we are in
the final stretch here super chats have
been closed but you can get a super
sticker in there if you want to still uh
Johnny y'all going to try these
spider-verse Whopper now I am I had the
ghost pepper Halloween one with the
orange and black bun last year so I'll
I'll try out the uh the spider-verse
Whopper before it goes in uh
I don't know if I can break my diet to
that scale but if I do it'd only be for
spider Spiderman only for Spider-Man
that hard cheat day dude I haven't even
crossed this for three months my first
few days are all in Italy I had another
cheat day in two and a half months I had
no cheat days that's how I dropped 22
pounds you should have gotten that
Burger King in Italy I should have then
it would have count I would have been
final wouldn't say imagine they'll go to
Atlanta getting Burger King like that's
right I'm around the best food and I'm
like you know what it's time for a
Whopper hey they had that Papa John's
with the hidden Cathedral inside for
Uncharted I did go to the first
McDonald's in Rome and it had uh like an
actual statue and bust and there was a
big thing that said like premiere of
McDonald's and there was like a plaque
it was the nicest McDonald's I've ever
been in but it was very alien good old
whack Arnold's uh olenti koi is such a
big brain hey thanks I got something in
my eye but I appreciate you better than
being a smooth brain and olenti thank
you for holding it down and for being so
generous today I really appreciate all
your input and all your love uh joyful
cheese the best kind of cheese all
cheese brings me joy but this cheese the
most love the content DC Marvel question
with the cast of Justice League changing
how uh about how with the cast of
Justice League changing how about hiring
gal Henry as Power Princess and Hyperion
for a Marvel Squadron Supreme you know
I'm a sucker for stunt casting I think
it'd be really fun to cast the
equivalent of the Justice League in
Marvel uh I really want to see Henry
Cavill
um being the authority and just upset a
lot of people because a lot of
homophobic people
um will not love that Henry Cavill is is
a gay character but I also understand
the the gay community wanting a gay
actor in that role but I I love any
casting give us a gay character you
can't cut out for China uh that's what
Authority is they're the leads it's
gonna be great uh but yeah I I love any
stunt casting like this so uh I'm in
Hell's to the yells and also just loving
the love in the chat uh uh Christian
unpronounceable good dude this kindness
happening and uh yeah I just love the
love pile that's happening over there
raccoon shampoo thank you so much for
the generous contribution to the chat
and uh and yeah I love your avatar as
well you are the rocket of the channel
my guy uh don't have anything to say at
the moment so good afternoon from
Chicago good afternoon to Chicago
I can't do much Jackson came in there I
don't know what it was but it was it was
there I was just like for at least one
word I gotta kind of kind of get there
one day I would love to visit Chicago
I've only ever been to the airport in
Chicago and that is also subsequently
the only place I've tried
a deep dish pizza which I'm not gonna
say is like an authentic I got a place
in L.A for you it's actually as a
Bostonian and uh every week every other
week in New Yorker I actually found a
deep dish place it's not it's not like
East Coast Pizza good and it's not quite
Chicago pizza good but it's not the
DiGiorno you get in La so it's in the
middle all right all right yeah you
heard me I like pizza you heard me L.A
of pizza is the one kind of thing
everyone who comes here is like the one
thing you can't please anyone with is
pizza the Thai food though the Mexican
food like there's a lot of good food
here yeah it's just not pizza that's uh
yeah the to balance to balance the
scales we suck at Pizza apparently and
congrats Andrew uh k
I hope you're just like at a variant of
Andrew WK uh for cheating with the
donuts cheat day it's good
um Stephanie Horton also had some
McDonald's cheat day in Rome so that's
good I appreciate that as well I was on
my like coach beard night and I was
drinking red absence wandering the
streets of Rome it was the only thing
open until 2 A.M and I had such a good
night it was amazing have a good one
Disney fan I would love to have an
experience like that boy I tell you
Chelsea Yellowjackets has been heavily
recommended to me and at some point I'm
gonna watch it I'm very excited
um Jeff uh crashing coyote Super Genius
Jeff Snyder said Tom uh from succession
is a TVA agent would that be Matthew
McFadden is he Tom oh I think so yeah
because that was our story earlier there
we go yeah okay oh yeah he definitely
looks like a TVA agent yeah oh a hundred
percent them's The Vibes yeah I buy that
it's like not quite typecasting but
kinda also your boy uh
he was great on an episode of Doctor Who
as Nikola Tesla oh that's awesome that's
a good call he's a very terrible
terrificness oh yeah he was a great
Tesla um and so yeah I could definitely
see uh Matthew McFadden being a TVA
agent I made a lot of sense to me and uh
and yeah fun way to incorporate him
because I think he could still have fun
with that Brendan V how's it going buddy
sending some love your way as well thank
you for contributing hey cuties hey you
how you doing David coronswet and Rachel
Brosnan for the win baby what are you
thinking on the Rachel Brosnan Lois Lane
uh there's a lot of good names for Lois
Lane like a lot I uh looked in like I've
actually been following the lowest uh
side of things more than the Superman
side of things but she is so good at
difficult dialogue uh Amy Sherman
Palladino is one of my favorite writers
and Amy Sherman Palladino writes
Marvel's Mrs maisel and I don't think
think that show Works without Rachel
Brosnahan and I don't think Lois Lane
Works without someone capable of
delivering uh not only like newspaper
jargon absurd comic book jargon but also
like she's in love with an alien yes
like there's a lot of dialogue that's
just gonna have to be like worked and I
I could I could easily see this also I
love like she loves so many people in
the show and like it shows so I like the
browsing handpick but I really there's
like five names I love for this Lois and
I I think that uh some of this on the
big thing with Christian and Winston the
the lowest Lane character I hope
actually ties into our conversation hey
remember when we were talking about like
the lack of like chemistry and love in
Marvel movies and DC movies the last 15
years sure I think that the lowest Lane
Superman relationship as written by
James Gunn will hopefully start shifting
this weird sexlessness yes and I don't
mean like sex listen like I need to see
my superheroes boning I mean sexist as
in like the worlds feels sterile and
like people don't love like if you look
at Tony and pepper two great
performances by the actors I do not
think they've had more than a firm
handshake like there's there's I want
there to be friction and tension and
love Yeah like the the clavicle showing
in eternals when it's like whoa whoa
whoa there's a section of Marvel I'm
like okay they're holding hands more in
that movie than that scene like that I
want there to be a world where people
like love each other we kill plenty we
should love more so Rachel Brosnan I
think could bring some passion and I
want it yeah yeah that was a long answer
but I I like that casting no and I mean
you know it's not the most engaged part
of the Guardians movies but I think you
know programs are free there is at least
a presence of love and a you know direct
confrontation of the ups and downs of
that versus just like hahaha like a
little I feel like yeah oftentimes we
just get like that we gotta put some
kind of love story in without it really
being you know
something that gets the TLC like the
other ones like Sony did it so well
Garfield in stone and then I think you
know Fox I think Deadpool is some of the
best love I've seen in genre content
like Vanessa but Vanessa and Wade like
they they feel like they actually love
each other yeah and pegging 100
Gracie and Ryan thank you so much for
joining in uh these very sexy profile
pic koi do you think kit Connor from
Heart Stopper would make a good Johnny
Storm pick perfect for Bromance with Tom
Holland's Peter parkour I do not know
Heart Stopper or this man but show me
okay here we go kit Connor sounds like a
Superman yeah
that guy got jacked uh he was in uh he
was Rocket Man Ready Player one he
wasn't the main guy in Ready Player one
because that was Cyclops yeah I don't
know this guy but uh you know we got
jacked he's a British actor so you know
he can do it but like it's so funny like
his photos from here like it looks like
four years ago he's like so young and
innocent and then like he's got these
bodybuilding photos but for him uh and
who does he want him as Johnny Storm
but um again Mason Gooding is one of my
Johnny storms for age because I think
him and uh him and Tom Holland I think
he's a little Lauren Town Hall but it
could work
um I don't know how they're gonna do
that relationship but this guy he
actually looks like a decent amount like
human torch I'm into that I love my
picture human torches jacked as this guy
recently got though I know he's like
these IMDb pictures are like insanely
dude got like yolk City good for him
yeah man I wonder was that is that the
first stopper or does it look like us
for hearts like this dude's like got a
uh like a not a not quite a bodybuilder
physique but close yeah look at this
like that's a that's a large man yeah he
got sick of all the soulless ginger
jokes and just got games yes say it to
my face Sean Jones appreciates you very
much for joining in cool I miss you on
break room and my brother Jace sucks uh
I don't know about your brother but uh
break room's got my number
and uh hey Jace step it Up all right
raccoon shampoo appreciate you chiming
back in being very generous today high
evolutionary doesn't have time travel
but he does have gravity and I don't
know science but don't gravity and time
have a relationship I suppose that could
be an in for Kang's time travel what's
funny is they actually used gravity with
Kang in the movie like all that all of
his powers instead of having him with
time because they were like he's in the
one place where he has no power over
time as a Time conqueror that was vexing
but uh man I think that character like
the acting versus the anyway
um I I like that tie-in I just again I I
don't know if I want to sacrifice high
evolutionaries arc for the sake of Kings
yeah yeah I feel that for sure it would
still feel like some kind of work around
rather than something natural yeah uh
not to say they couldn't but yeah at the
outset anyway Bucky Barnes ATL thank you
so much for holding it down in the chat
and uh for contributing here as well and
for moderating and just being all around
awesome
uh and yes love to see the high
evolutionary work with Mr Sinister what
do you think I think they're very
similar and I actually was wondering
when I was watching it uh if they would
be able to use the history time soon
because the Sinister was supposed to be
the the big uh culminating event after
like New Mutants and he got teased like
he'd been cast a few times John Ham most
recently Cranston wanted to play him uh
so Fox was leading towards Sinister and
now that you know High evolutionary is
in there I don't know if they can
because everybody like wait we just saw
this but if they do bring him in I think
they'd work very well together they have
similar goals absolute vodka also just
real quick Lucas uh vakulik I hope I'm
saying your name right hello to you uh
out in the Czech Republic and uh keep
studying you know keep at it with your
film studies and thank you guys so much
for watching shouts out to you I
actually have a little Czech Heritage in
my timeline when we did that when we did
our 23andMe and Greg got his whole like
magic adventure of things uh and I got
my verification of everything I've been
told one of those verifications was that
I do indeed have some uh Czech Heritage
so uh you have a great night as well and
thank you for chiming in thank you for
tuning in I had the John experience
where I was like well that's everything
I've ever said it looks like I was right
uh yep thanks 85.9 Irish I am a thing oh
boy I was so I like I've always said
seven eighths and I got 85.9 I was like
well all right math checks out not that
bad uh Dom thoughts oh this is a good
one for koi thank you for joining into
the uh super chats here thoughts on
Alden Aaron Reich as a red hood anytime
my boy Alden can work and play and do
something he wants I'm in uh I've always
thought Alden had this like really
wonderful brooding quality about him and
I think Red Hood uh has seen some stuff
so I feel like Alden would crush as like
the brooder side actually used to think
of Alden as a a good multiversal Batman
because I think he's a little too short
for Batman but like a a multiversal and
red hood kind of suits that so I
actually really like that take because
it solves the problem cosigned totally
totes magotes a Christian
unpronounceable thank you once again
keeping it strong in the super chats
would you you cast Who Would You cast is
Jubilee and why would it piss off
Brandon Barrett brand America is one of
the hosts over at New rockstars he is
obsessed with Jubilee uh I'm gonna get
this name and make sure I have it right
and also make sure she wasn't in another
uh opposing property give me just one
moment no no I want to make I'm
cross-referencing other casting for
safety tap into the Mainframe koi pen
Badgley is read interesting choice could
kind of see that sure Melissa Ben West
as Sue storm Rudy panko as Johnny that's
my fan cast ooh that's fun ooh Rudy
pankow I know that name right I feel
like I can see all your picks not bad
you should jump into some casting over
here why not guys uh and yeah Lindsay
the eternals did Have Some Lovin I I
just feel like it was more stoic you
know sort of serene loving and I want to
see some you know some passion you know
I want to sizzle I want that chemistry
you know okay she's not in the MCU yet I
just made sure also Lana Khan door
should have gotten her time as Jubilee
because Lana Condor is incredible and
she was so good in deadly class which
never have been canceled but since Lana
Condor is probably not coming back I
want an older Jubilee for a bunch of
reasons one I think the character
leaning young is part of why people
don't take her seriously two if she's an
80s Mall kid she'd be older by now and
that's a key part of her character three
because I want him to cast Jessica
henwick absolutely anything Jessica
henwick would be a great idea emcee of
Jubilee's Creek nether 22 back at it
again thank you so much I'm loving all
the Alan Richardson love as am I I've
loved him through Smallville Thad in
Blue Mountain State Hawking Titans
Reacher I cannot wait for MCU or DC and
uh and yeah I'm gonna be sitting here
just counting down the days because I
think richson in one of these I mean you
know at a certain point it becomes the
conversation where it's just like put
everybody into this franchise and
certainly I think everybody's at some
point will be in it but uh I would be
especially excited were he to be cast
get intense Cyclops ah yeah cause like
cyclops has been like extra yoked and I
think it'd be a really interesting way
to make the uh the Jean Gray decision of
Cyclops to Wolverine interesting if
Wolverine's actually short and then
you've got a beast of a cyclops like the
the guy I tell you Wolverine needs to
look like he smells real bad so if
you've got like this this figure of of
perfect physique and then this little
hairy Canadian I'd love that hairy
Canadians Alistair McDonald
thank you so much for chiming in uh BMS
is so good just re-watched it since
watching Reacher because of you guys
happy to see Koy back have a great
weekend from Scotland thank you so much
I got some Scottish in my Heritage as
well and I guess I'm gonna have to check
out some Blue Mountain State and uh I've
not seen Blue Mountain State much love
to Scotland also someone just mentioned
something I totally forgot and Alden is
an Earnhardt Alden Erin Reich is an iron
heart I put all that together Alden is
an iron heart fun be looking out for
that
excited uh Mustafa jav how do you think
Sabra will be portrayed in the MCU as a
Palestinian American I have mixed
feelings about all of it uh I mean Sabra
is a newish character um I don't
I I don't think there's any sort of
representation of a lot of folks in the
Middle East and I think that I don't
know I I'm torn because I feel like uh
Omission is worse than than
um
handling it poorly is obviously awful
but not handling at all is at the cost
of handling poorly is dangerous because
then like people don't have anything to
attach to I think there's a fear of
including
certain people which is ignorant and
that is way worse than not like I feel
like we're only recently out of this
like cast a person that is of an
ethnicity and label them a blank and
we're finally getting to the point where
like I've always said the win is going
to be when like a female director of any
kind directs an Avengers movie versus
like a female director directing Captain
Marvel I think a win is going to be when
we cast
um you know a black actor is Cyclops and
that's not the entire conversation I
think those are what I see the wins as
so I think we're even further behind
with a lot of Middle Eastern culture I
think that the Muslim representation of
Miss Marvel was a huge part of my draw
to the character in the comic books and
I loved how it was portrayed in the show
I know nothing about like the
Palestinian conflict that I didn't learn
off YouTube videos and I think it'd be
really important to have a character
that is authentically telling that but I
think any of that will at least nudge
things in the right direction but I'm an
85.9 white guy so I hope they just do
anything right like I I don't know if
I'm the person to ask I just I hope they
handle it well I don't know is any
answer but it's all very intense I I
would be uh inclined to agree with you
and yes Jessica henwick was Colleen wing
and I was Fist and uh hello to the
country of Peru the entire thing all of
you guys and uh Hey Mustafa jav thank
you for that uh and and yeah I would
love to hear your thoughts on it as well
I know you said you're pretty mixed on
it so be curious to hear kind of what
you're weighing in your brainpan Noah uh
Norrell s hey guys hello to you and
thank you for joining in uh John are you
guys gonna come out with more Rio
rejects hoodies or sweaters anytime soon
you know the the main push goes to
having a new T-shirt design up every
month or so uh and and Greg you know has
you know certainly a lot of those in the
pipeline and is sort of The Mastermind
that guides those but uh if you guys
have I mean the best way to kind of
communicate that demand is certainly by
letting us know in comments or whatever
um and we do have the one hoodie but
yeah if that's something that you guys
are really into let us know and the more
people who ask for it you know maybe
there will be an opportunity to try out
a sweater or a hoodie or some other
variation on that it's just you know
t-shirt seems to be the most universal
Nexus of like attainable for people
um but yeah Sovereign debuted much
earlier than I thought I thought she was
a 2000s character Sabra was incredible
256 in 1981. did not realize that's a
much older character than I thought
thank you Garth not bad Garth holding
down the fact checking over there and we
got some eternals love in the chat as
well uh some some folks find it quite
beautiful one of us Jordan Garza welcome
back and thank you so much for the for
the intense generosity today guys Hawk
and Dove casting both Dawn and Dawn go
um I'm casting Hawk from Cobra Kai and
I'm casting uh Dove Cameron who do you
got
I'm casting Bruce Willis from Hawk uh
Hudson Hawk and I'm casting
um uh the doves from Mission Impossible
2. sure any of the John Woo doves I
actually don't know uh Hawk and Dove
that well I I was mainly joking but I
actually these are characters uh I I
don't follow deeply yeah I I mean I want
uh looking at this one picture here I
want it to be Jane Lynch and a really
jacked Fred Willard there it is uh Ethan
sou play and uh
uh Emma Stone cool I'm for it they look
like these renderings are cool so I wish
I I had a better answer yeah is there a
blind spot for me because yeah because
uh just just real quick just just look
at that look at how cool that looks yeah
so uh hey who would you cast let us know
and uh and then yeah next time we'll
have better answers doe eyes appreciate
the super sticker I love this little
black cat reminds me of Todd one of
Greg's Cat's very sweet cat love a good
cat and uh love you as well doe eyes you
got a cat in your uh profile pic too so
all the feline Love Today Joel Rolston
we're almost to the end folks again
thank you so much for your love and
contributions uh okay hear me out we
will Guardians and ravagers meet Silver
Surfer and Captain Marvel introduces the
Shia Empire possible I do think Captain
Marvel's gonna introduce the sheer
Empire like very soon in November uh I
did not think about the Guardians
meaning Silver Surfer though that's very
fun uh I don't know how much the
ravagers are going to come into play
because of who they are um like you know
Stallone probably not gonna you know be
as around in the MCU uh with his
schedule and also
um I think Zoe Saldana has said she's
done but uh so I don't know if I'll see
the ravages again but uh I love the idea
of the Guardians uh having any sort of
Adventures of Silver Surfer that's
really fun absolutely and uh hey we can
finally get that Keanu in here yes I
want him so bad I keep you perfect Robin
West Parker thank you so much for coming
in good to see you again uh this is the
only Channel I can show up an hour after
the notification you guys are still
going cheers to you that's right that's
how we do it we can never just keep it
to one two hours at 40. I don't know how
John campio used to do it uh but yeah I
appreciate you sticking it out and
that's we're here for people like you
and people like me because that's
usually who I would be uh Kiana Chanel
thank you so much for being here for
contributing and for holding it down in
the chat as well always great to see
y'all's faces great to see yours as well
or at least the part of it I can see in
your little Avatar picture have a happy
Saturday handsome dudes and you yourself
have a happy Saturday lovely lady and uh
I hope uh yeah that your day is going
well uh gracian Ryan
a little moment of silence here at the
end of the day also here's a little
highlight of the text in there in the
super chat so you can see it yeah good
good uh Gracie and Ryan appreciate that
little moment of silence at the very end
here dtk Dave also from you really
appreciate the generosity and all you
guys really like again you guys are the
fuel of these conversations uh you know
there are always some predetermined
topics uh you know that Greg pulls
together for these but you know you guys
drive so much of what the interest is
and we just appreciate to no end your
enthusiasm and your support and your
willingness to you know join us for
these and to you know be patient with
the process and all that other good
stuff and uh and yeah you guys make this
really special so I'm just gonna refresh
these one more time but koi do you have
any stray thoughts to end us off with uh
I think it's very exciting that we're
going into summer as of fast 10 dropping
yesterday I think it is uh the longest
gap between now and September between
giant properties is two weeks and most
things are like two days five days like
we're about to get into the thick of it
I'm very excited for uh spiderverse in
two weeks or a week and uh I'm very
excited for Flash doing the Raptor I
don't know like I'm I'm I feel like it's
summer so I mean I'm excited like we're
about to be with you guys a lot more
these are references sure uh guys we are
all caught up and that is gonna do it
for our time today uh thank you all for
being here shout out a few names at the
end here uh olenti appreciates you being
here and just for again engaging with
the discussion Jen Jacinda uh it's a
pleasure to take out the time and and we
really appreciate you all for joining us
Lil Bosch 31 uh seeing the flash very
soon in fact so keep an eye out for
those early reviews uh non-spoiler and
then probably a spoiler live stream to
follow that uh Rocky 67 Chelsea EP Bucky
Barnes holding it down with the
moderation Collision uh doe eyes
Christian unpronounceable Garth McMurray
nether 22 Robin Wes Parker go Hanson 27
Calvin Patel so many guys like the I
want to name all of you I wish we could
uh amber Lilly I am definitely gonna be
cast as Reed Richards that's mainly why
you haven't heard anything to if the
atom driver thing is just a smoke screen
for right now it's working
um Dom stamina MC G cobp all you guys
thank you so much for being here for
chatting it up with us and yeah for
helping guide our uh Saturday morning
greetings to Germany Wonder Woman mellow
Richard faring enjoy the rest of your
weekend and uh yeah that's gonna do it
so thank you very much guys don't forget
to leave a like on the stream uh you
know if you think of something else go
back and leave a comment on the replay
and we will catch you next time much
love for now and uh cheers to all of you
video dropping tomorrow another one
you're gonna be excited about it oh yeah
keep an eye out you said that in behind
the chat box say it say it with your
face tomorrow video yeah one that we
really enjoy dropping tomorrow a series
is back more DC goodness is happening so
keep an eye out and uh we will see you
next time be well super sexy rejects of
the reject Nation citizens and uh yeah
peace be with you
and